three two
ladies and gentlemen the champ is here
my man salute salute last time
last time you were here
you were neither the interim nor the
undisputed now you got it all i'm the
double interim channel you got it why
why say w you keep saying that double
interim double interim i don't know
because
whitaker's the champ yeah he was you
knocked him out you're the champ because
when i was there you know even my last
fight i feel like it's my first title
defense to be honest because i was
waiting for something to change i was
waiting for that feeling that i had in
atlanta but never came and within three
days i was like i felt like i just
defended the belt because technically i
was the champ as well
i was the champ and if he had beat me
he'd have got one of those rubies you
put on this so i'm looking for my ruby
as well they get a ruby yeah like that's
the thing you don't get you know i used
to get a new belt yeah you don't get a
new build anymore so what they do is
they you send this off
this isn't actually my one my one i've
sent it off this isn't yours yeah but
you're saying yours already i sent you
take this plaque off this plaque on the
side and then you send it off then they
put a ruby and send it back to you you
put a ruby in the plaque yeah so you
collect like the infinity stones or
whatever oh
[ __ ] yeah
yeah dude i used to not like this belt
now i like it better it's grown yeah it
took me like maybe two days after
everyone complained about it and i
looked at it and then when i first saw
it i think it was at the pi and i was
like you know what
i [ __ ] with it yeah i for a while i was
like ah the old one was better now i'm
like i don't think so anymore i like
nostalgia nostalgia yeah it gets you
every time this one's cleaner yeah it's
just like sharp more legible the old one
it was cool and i still like to i could
buy one on the website hopefully yeah
but those are light yeah but you just
for like nostalgic purposes and just
because you know i've been a fan i
should have got one of those i came at
the end of it colby's still walking
around with one
man don't get attached to these things
man i only i flex with them for a little
bit you know because
even my um my last after after atlanta
my coach he was kind of worried because
i was going to nigeria i was doing all
these shows i got to like show it off
flex it but he's my coach so eugene's
like man you know don't think you're the
champ yet but i'm like yeah i'm the
champ but then there was a point when we
moved gyms and i just kind of all right
put in this box with everything else and
then he kind of posted about it because
he saw like okay the switch happened
like it's game time now so same thing
i'm doing my tour right now victory tour
walk around do all this [ __ ] but then
even being at the fights last weekend i
got fomo
because you know after the fights i uh
you know i see what's up people talking
about me right or right or so i'm like
man i gotta get back to the gym so when
i get back i don't even look at this
thing that's interesting so you're aware
that
you could get too
into the moment yeah you can get too
wrapped up in the fact that you won the
title and maybe slack off a little bit
but maybe take yourself too seriously
cause i mean a lot of people this is
their goal
they're like i want to become the ufc
champion they get it done and then what
happens after in the next fight
they lose it right they lose sight track
of
what really matters so some guys like
kobe for example he's walking around
with the belt when used man whips his
ass so if ozman whips his ass then
what's going to happen you're going to
walk around with that bill how are you
going to feel
well i
the kobe thing is interesting and i
don't know how much kobe wants people
talking about this but i'm going to i'm
going to spill it as much as i can
that's an act man it's a strong act that
he put on when they were ready to cut
him they were ready you talked to that
guy in real life he's very respectful
jeff's being around him just being and
said he's the nicest guy he's a nice guy
man he's playing a pro wrestling heel
and he's got the whole world worked up
it sells
and here's the thing though this is
where it's interesting
it tricks people because he seems like a
goof he wears a stupid [ __ ] cheap
blue suit he wears that maga hat does
that smile he's got the old belt yeah
you know it's not a legit belt right but
he did win the interim title and they
took it from him for no reason it
doesn't make any sense so there's this
thing about him where people somehow
another think like maybe he's
illegitimate maybe he's not real then he
[ __ ] robbie lawler he can work and you
go oh jesus this guy doesn't get tired
he could strike his wrestling's on point
his [ __ ] cardio is off the chart he's
tough as nails yeah i was impressed
but when he put ruby against the fence
he was right there slipping and ripping
oh yeah some things you know everyone
has holes in the game i have holes in my
game but he was really impressive the
way he was right there in his face yes
robbie lawler he's not an elite striker
in the sense of like he's a guy who will
slip and then blast someone unconscious
with one shot he's a volume guy he's
throwing sixty percent fifty sixty
percent just on you on you on youtube
yep never let you rest never let you
rest and robbie in that fight and brav
he's a [ __ ] all-time great
welterweight champion i mean he was a
legit top of the food chain [ __ ]
and he was looking for those openings
that were never there he was always
looking for colby to slow down colby
never slowed down he was waiting he
would have seen him like just waiting
waiting and he was just like buying this
time looking to explode okay [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah here it is here it is and there's
ways to do that like i did it against um
whitaker as well
you see it
excuse me i always got a burp um
it's times when he'll like i'll put a
clip off of this it's like a simple one
shifting real simple subtle thing you
just move two step one two that's it
i can see it when he'll like bounce
bounce all right i'm ready to go you
shift you disrupt the pattern okay reset
reset but about to attack you know
wonderboy did it to um lukay yeah past
weekend you know whenever he was
bouncing he's either he's gonna bounce
bounce and then one boy shifts so he was
doing it with the offense bounce bounce
bounce attack yeah so he was just it's
all about rhythm yeah i love that well
you have something that wonder boy has
that a few other people have in that
you're a specialist
and that being a specialist and
obviously you have a full game
you there's no way you get to where you
are without a full game but you you are
an elite striker thank you and
with that that's that's a giant
advantage because on the feet you are a
step ahead of everybody every fight
starts standing on the feet you see it
with whitaker because whitaker's a great
striker he's a tough guy but he had
holes in his game that maybe he didn't
even know he had yeah but you you could
say you know what it was i got in his
head and everyone like when
i can see this kind of stuff man
before the press before the fight the
press conference when he was talking and
acting all unbothered and stuff like
that and i was like what he's acting out
of character people
he put this meme up right and then
people thought i was affected by the
meme but all that showed me was like
you've never talked [ __ ] or poked fun at
anyone you're fighting but somehow
suddenly you're poking phone at me
that's showing your first card showing
you first hand
and a lot of things he did throughout
the like back back tracking and whatnot
i was like you're showing me your hand
you're acting out of character even my
coach said the same thing and i said
just do what got you to the dance don't
try and talk [ __ ] with a guy who knows
how to talk [ __ ] i know he knows how to
talk [ __ ] with his friends and [ __ ] like
that but not with me the internet kid is
different don't make memes against me
i'm the mean majesty
but like yeah so and then when he when
he came to the cage you know so you saw
me when i walked up i stomped the yard
stomped the yard and i entered the cage
and when he came in
i could i could feel it he was like
let's [ __ ] go you know beating this
thing he did
and
he took about a minute and a bit before
he looked me in the eyes and i was i was
looking at him the whole time and he
like a cat you corner even a chicken get
one of your chickens corner it like a
rooster it's dangerous
when you corner any kind of beast
they'll attack you at any point so i
could see him pacing back and forth like
a caged animal
and the whole time like he was the
hunter he was the hunter and i was the
pr i was i was the hunter so i was
watching him and i could feel it like
you're not really about this and he's
trying to hype himself let's [ __ ] go
and i could just smell that and when i
went in my stance
i started whoop like this is something i
was doing during sparring like during my
my training camp so i was just
triggering this this like muscle memory
in my head and i was just having fun
there's a point i looked at him i kind
of smiled like [ __ ] yeah i got this and
i just knew from that point man i was
honest in the first round i thought i
lost the first round without the
knockdown just like
i let him have it but then i watched it
back
i threw less strikes i landed more he
threw more strikes and nonetheless all i
was doing was just
me and eugene talked about this light
let the first round the first half of
the fight let's see what he does
just get all his attacks draw make him
show his hand make him draw you know
draw draw the attacks out of him and i
did that and after i watched it again i
was like yeah without the knock then i
still had the round
it was a brilliant performance and the
the knock down at the end of the first
round was essentially the end of the
fight yeah he was [ __ ] up it was there
was a bad knock down you could see when
he went back to his corner there's
there's a moment where you see
his eyes are just not quite there yeah
like after even before the second round
he stood up and when calvin rocked me
after i got rocked my first time being
rocking the ufc
in the second round i was before the
second round i was all right let's go
let's step it up he was looking at the
screen robert was looking at the screen
like what hit me won't hit me and i was
like hey
hey
that's in the past that's done focus on
me right now anyway
i was all right then let's go yeah yeah
um when it was over yeah when they
stopped the fight raise your hand
what's that feeling like knowing that
you're the undisputed champ it felt like
just my title defense honestly atlanta
atlanta was the one where they put my
hand up and i felt like yes why why
atlanta why that because the fight was
so hard yeah i think because of the way
the fight went the back and forth and
then me
that that fifth round like i i found out
who i was after that like that fifth
round i found out the depths i'm willing
to go so when they put my hand up and
you know you're beat up and all that
kind of stuff just and also i never had
a belt before so i've never had it
wrapped around my waist as i visualized
it so once that happened boom i felt
like yes and also i was looking i was
like please judges don't screw me over
don't [ __ ] me over on this man and i
knew i had it but you know you never
know exactly bruh dude and then look at
the darren till gaston fight so when
they put my hand up i was like yes but
then this time they put my hand up i was
like all right
what's that and thing is
my brain wants to move forward
because i did it in kickboxing because i
was undefeated for so long so it was
always alright cool what's next i'll
watch the fight maybe once study it
alright what's next but now i have to
like chill
relax
look at the tape look at what you've
done and then soak it in smell the roses
for a little bit and then move on yeah
because once i had my first loss
i i took winning for granted because it
was just a habit i was always winning
always winning i was winning so now i
have to like when you win when you do
something amazing like i did in atlanta
like i did in melbourne just chill smell
the roses and then move forward
when you
entered the fifth round against kelvin
you said i'm ready to die it was i
looked at him and i remember i called
este diablo he was looking at me
and he just had this like look and he's
just swinging his hands and i said
you're not going to beat me i'm prepared
to die and i meant that man i swear to
god on my life i meant that i'm even
getting goosebumps thinking see that i'm
getting goosebumps like i meant that
[ __ ] cause i was like look and i signed
i signed my death warrant right there i
was like look if this is how i died this
is how i die but
you see me i was trying to get him i was
trying to kill him i knew because for me
if i'm ready to die i'm ready to kill
you have to be willing to give something
up as well
so in that fifth round when i was
throwing those shots when i was i think
i dropped him like four times or
something crazy like
even the last one like went from heaven
hit him i wish i didn't like follow
and like roll over on him because i
probably could have got him out with
like two seconds left
but i was trying to get him out of there
man and it's sad to say but i was ready
if he had taken it to me and he if he
had done that to me and i didn't wake up
so be it
well that was
evident in the way you fought because
you did you didn't you know it was a
close fight but it looked like you were
ahead on the judges but you didn't take
i mean any
break at all you just you threw yourself
into the fire instead of being cautious
you know and i told that to dana you
know dana and i were talking about that
fight and he was he was talking about
how hyped he is for whitaker they tried
to get me to fly to australia
i love you bro but i'm not doing that
don't do it
with me try like right now i've canceled
a lot of my trips because also you know
my knee but also just fomo being away
from the gym like
you feel it after a while at this level
like after the fight because you can see
the target on your back people smiling
your face you know oh yeah and then
yeah i know what's up i'm not stupid
i've seen a lot of people in this game
rise and fall 100 all the time so i want
to get back to doing what i do best dana
and i have these conversations sometimes
we get hyped up and talk on the phone
and we were talking about that fight and
i said do you know what he said
you literally said it yeah i have it on
my um it's a highlight i made by myself
and then i had it in the captions and i
was like you know you're not you're
going to beat me i'm ready to die i'm
prepared to die
that's a movie type [ __ ] that is movie
type [ __ ] especially when you win yeah
100 and dana just went holy [ __ ] i said
dude watch it just watch it again he's
saying i mouthed it yeah yeah
it wasn't lip
that was a hell of a fight man it was a
hell of a fight yeah i don't want to
have much much like those but you have
to get that because after that fight
even like probably about two minutes
after i was like
i can go another two rounds i felt it i
was like this is like the third wind wow
oh [ __ ] and i'm not just saying this
like gas you up i'm saying like i was
like
i can go another two rounds and you can
see it like i felt freshman i've never
this is my that was my second fifth five
round fight when i fought this time last
year against um what's his name on july
last year brad tavares
fifth round i was just having fun i
didn't even like i wouldn't say i took
my foot off the pedal but i was having
fun with it and this fight like i said
you know fifth round i was ready and i
said that for the romero fight and um
what's his name whitaker if i said look
look how he looked in the fifth round
he's got gas don't get me wrong he can
he can crack something with romero but
romero
and him they don't have the same kind of
spice as i do you know when i'm in when
i'm in the trenches when it's time to go
i can go because i do it in the gym
every day
you wanted romero for your next fight
sometimes man
you know i mean he's coming off three
out of four losses three in a row so i'm
like yeah but all of those could have
been his yeah i know but and also the
people the people the casuals they think
this is the guy well first well i think
brunson was a guy
and then gaslim was a guy yeah and then
whitaker is the guy so they think this
is the guy to beat me so i'm like all
right
this is my charity work for the year
well he's an interesting fight for
anybody yeah 100 because he's a freak
athlete i mean that if you look up freak
in the dictionary you see a picture of
yoel romero flying through the air
hitting chris weidman with his knees
yeah i mean he's just a freak i remember
his first fight i saw him he did the
same thing to this black guy bald black
guy flying knee boom and just kind of
starts them just ran at him
but
this is lev this is what this is what
rises me to the occasion this is what
challenges me because a guy like that
like you say he's a beast
same thing with robert he's a beast yep
but there's levels to this and if you
can make that look easy
it just makes you look that like your
status
legendary go all that [ __ ] that's what
you want yeah so you want something nice
but it just looks good you know what i'm
saying but it's all about the the
challenges taking out robert whitaker in
the second round in his home country you
know doing that to your romero maybe not
in cuba i don't know what the situation
is like there but like in vegas in a big
arena t-mobile arena
that would be [ __ ] dope yeah but
dana said you know he's got to get a win
first day
thing is they don't know how to sell it
like to the people and i'm like [ __ ] it
let's do it anyway and i've said and
even his manager at the fights for
whatever reason while i was walking was
like hey israel we signed the country
and i was like i didn't know who it was
he's like hey we signed the contract
just tell dana i was like
okay
i had my drink in my hand i'm walking
like cool story bro we signed the card
what the [ __ ] does that dana said this
yeah but he was trying to say that's the
hype and then like someone might they
sent me this other video of him in the
gym saying israel why are you backing
now why are you backing her you know
just tell dana the [ __ ] day i'm like
you know he can love me
but i'm saying like i want to do the
fight i said look this is the guy right
this is the guy he's gonna take me down
and beat the [ __ ] out of me okay
no one's been able to do that yet so
let's see if this guy can do it or let's
see if i can take him down well yeah the
thing is too you have to get him now
because he's 41 now i think 40 41. he's
older yeah and that's when i beat him as
well that's what they're going to say oh
you know you beat up you know he's still
looking through i keep telling people
when he fought robert they didn't have
that narrative no they didn't say beat
whitaker i think the second time he'd be
with yeah he dropped him in yeah he
heard them
and if you look at those ten eight rules
you know the the new new rules he won
yeah if you look at you you're judging
by the new judging system he won i
thought he won period i just thought he
won yeah i mean and whittaker's a
[ __ ] animal man he hung in there with
that guy blasting him on the chin but he
hurt him and he hurt him bad yeah
several times
but uh the polo costa fight oh my god my
guy
that's your boy
my favorite friend living la vida
let's go i felt like that that fight was
legit either one could have got that
tied i think i i agreed with it when
costa wanted said okay i could see that
but if they gave it to romero i would be
like well i could see that too
i think costa won that fight like i said
he just stole it just yeah i think
that's the way to look at it
when he dropped him in the first round
that really solidified it and romero was
trying his best to come back but
just a step behind in my eyes anyway
like you said if hey roll the dice
sometimes
the thing is shocking about romero is
how well he takes a shot
there's a picture of costa kicking him
in the head that i put on instagram
where it looks like his soul is leaving
his body like his eyes are rolling back
in his head that shin is wrapping around
his head his whole head is distorted i
think it's the truth flinch that's all
those tracks right yeah it just holds
his head in place holds his breath in
place
doesn't move well you know he had a
pretty severe neck injury if you look at
the back of his neck he's got a giant
scar up his neck he had his discs fused
look at that picture damn what in the
[ __ ] dude that distorted i sent his face
into the [ __ ] black hole of another
universe
[ __ ] i mean that is full impact
yes it's all in robert did one on him as
well but this is a lot cleaner yeah a
lot nicer god damn i mean he's he's
taking giant shots i think brunson hit
him with a high head kick as well
wrapped around the neck nothing
i i think his neck is like one solid
piece yeah it just goes right i don't
know what the [ __ ] they did in cuba to
his neck when they did that operation on
it but he's all fused up and he walked
kind of stiff does he you know i've seen
him around he's especially when he's not
cutting weight like he's a heavy
i've seen very flexible see him doing
the splits yeah doing that dance on one
clip
that cuban olympic program is no joke i
mean when he described it he came on
with joey diaz and did you i saw yeah
it was amazing because joey was
translating from cuba to english and
they were talking about the program
like they they just train them and they
put them in this situation where if you
win you get more food and you get a
better place to stay
and if you lose you get two meals a day
if you lose you get three meals a day if
you win and these guys are they're
competing against the best in the world
yeah and
it's just every day is battle battle you
know he's like everybody i'm with wants
to kill me
and you become a machine
you may become a machine
it's just like you know and you see the
dude first of all when you're sitting
across from me like okay with you i know
you're heavier than 185 pounds but it's
feasible
what do you like what do you walk around
at like right now i guess 203. yeah
right now that's feasible
man in america you got to realize man
the food oh my god like i i forget every
time you got to order small
because you order naturals like
large they come in a platter yeah people
like to get fat yeah over here we like
everything yeah metabolism for me you're
lucky yeah yeah we like everything big
over here everything outrageous yeah
this is outrageous country
exhibit
blow torch well you were saying even
drinks they pour bigger drinks over here
like
i'm surprised like i think it's part of
the culture as well like you order you
say a double they're like no it comes in
a double i'm like oh
double double and then literally you
have to ask for more coke or more
fantasy
yeah yeah the ice helps though man
do you like new zealand you enjoy new
zealand like there was a time
from i think it was on going into the
new years of 2011 i was driving down
from auckland to wanganui
and i was just going through by myself
in my old car chewing
rapping singing just having fun and i
was just looking at the landscape
and that was the moment i decided that
this is where i'm going to stay this is
the country i'm going to live in because
i always had this idea that i'm going to
go to canada or america eventually but
also because my gym is over there my
team's over there eugene's over there my
family i've made friends there i've
grown up there it's my it's my other
country you know so i love it over there
i love the vibe as well it's a beautiful
have you you haven't been here i haven't
been there
i saw chad mendes went through
and got a big red yeah you go out there
you can catch something man like that's
like a 13 point i counted before
oh yeah you can get some [ __ ] yeah they
have giant stags i just imagine like
that with something that's 800 pounds
behind it yeah what is that thousand
pounds something yeah that one that i
have out in the front was over a
thousand pounds [ __ ] the one when you
walk in yeah it's huge now i've seen
some next to cars as well on youtube you
kind of just get some perspective
yeah yeah [ __ ] have you eaten any of
that see i told you the story
that's made
yeah what was the place costco i asked i
was gonna go to utah not utah i was
gonna go um to alex volkonovsky's fight
so i asked her where can i go get a
chili bin and i went to costco while
they were cleaning out the airbnb and i
also had some nigerian food i ordered as
well from texas so when i got back
racks to everything and i was like [ __ ]
and then you text me how to cook it and
everything and my coach using because i
really wanted to she's a hunter avid
hunter like after fights first place he
goes in the bush because he wants to get
away from all this
so i was like i gotta share this with
him and then yeah they rax them man i'm
sure they kept it
they threw it in the bin i'm sure they
kept it but i hope they enjoyed it yeah
yeah but i got to try some milk one day
definitely i will any time man anytime
you run here
we want to set up a kitchen in here oh
in the studio this is like the new
fantasy factory
actually you walk around i'm like man i
need one of these you're doing one day
yeah yeah i have a gym and right next to
the gym a fun house yeah yeah you know
it's it's good to have everything where
i could do it all in one place too yeah
because me i i just don't have any time
yeah so you need everything right yeah
it helps i can come in here two hours
before a show get a full workout in
shower everything even sauna but you
know get it all done in one spot yeah if
you got a kitchen definitely i could
have made me a sandwich yeah man well we
got a little baby kitchen but we got it
we got to set up a grill in here um what
i was getting about new zealand is the
beauty man like there's something i
think that like when people think about
places and places to live you know you
think oh it's convenient this is an easy
commute this is you know it's a nice
apartment or it's a nice house whatever
it is but there's something about
natural beauty
and it doesn't really get much beautiful
more beautiful than new zealand in the
south island as well like the north
island school there's some spots there's
a lot of places like for me i travel all
around the world
but whenever like i fly in and i see the
sky tower and you can see the grant like
the landscape of the place that's
beautiful and i feel like like marshall
when he sees the hills and he's about to
go for a hike i was like yes almost home
almost home but like it's such a
beautiful place and when you queen's
queens queens queenstown the south
island the snow there i haven't been
i've seen everyone posting about it but
one day i'm going to go there's snow in
new zealand [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah mount
ruapehu that's where i've been snowing
snowboarding years ago wow south island
i've been to years ago when i was
younger like 12
but
definitely as an adult i got to go it's
different when you go with your parents
and when you're going as adults so i got
to go out there man it's [ __ ]
beautiful it's a crazy place when it
comes to wildlife because they brought
it all from europe yeah they did even
like i'm surprised um in auckland
there's an island called waiheke island
it's um
probably about a 20-minute ferry ride
from the city and there's wallabies on
there i had no idea and apparently there
are invasive species because the guy
brought them from australia but then
luckily they kept on the island now but
i've heard like rumors now they've kind
of found their way because you know some
crazy [ __ ] decided i'm gonna keep this
of course
yeah they're on their way to like
rotorua the redwoods and all that kind
of [ __ ] it's only some crazy [ __ ] that
wants a pet i know
florida's got a giant problem with that
yeah with uh what is it an economist
uh anacondas what do you call it uh
what's that guy tarzan guy he catches
them all the time
iguanas iguanas as well there's a lot of
them and they're killing them now
they're trying yeah they're culling them
they give you money if you kill iguanas
really yeah because they're digging
under houses oh they dig tunnels in
their houses
foundations collapse
i thought they were just in trees i
thought so too yeah he learned something
new every day
they have so many pythons there they
said there's no more rabbits there's no
more marsh hares
raccoons deer everything's gone all
pythons pythons are eating alligators
yeah oh yeah i've seen i see them and
they burst out like see their legs
sticking out and [ __ ] like that they
even found nile crocodiles in in the
everglades really sounds crazy
crocodiles yeah they have a kill-on-site
warning isn't it like they even it was
it texas they have more
tigers yep or lions yeah that was my
netflix special yeah there's more tigers
than all of the wild of the world crazy
yeah
this is so crazy do you spend much time
out there i've been there when i first
went there was when i think when i first
met you ufc 192 uh dc gustafson
yeah i was there it was a good time i
didn't really i just ate that's all i
did there just eating hanging out yeah
barbie dan was cutting
i asked him how you feeling he's i feel
great i'm like yeah you feel great i i
was hooked
i was a mark
then afterwards he's like no i don't
have to light weight and you see him at
lightweight now [ __ ] bro i'm
telling you he's the one
because i would say i was yeah well i've
seen some things man
he's a tough guy i've had him on my back
for four minutes
of a five minute round spying and he's
hard to get off and he's good like
you know some people in the gym they
shine and some people under the bright
lights they shine some people can do
both and i'm telling you yeah he he's
the one like people don't know yet
there's some things he hasn't shown of
his game that i'm
i'm sure that like so i was in the room
when dc and john anik were doing like
the you know the fighter um
what do you call it interview so i did
my one first and then
they did dan and dan was telling me like
john asked about the champ you know so
you know how would you beat khabib and
he said he just saw dc go
like lean in like what and then he had
to kind of just you know say some
[ __ ] or whatever but right yeah like
i know because even like dc asked me to
help me help him train for the jones
fight uh the second one and i turned it
down because they had rock holes in
their camp and i wasn't in the ufc at
the time but i knew
i don't want to give them anything right
i don't want to give them anything i
don't want them to say oh he came to our
camp like i did with black zillions and
then they said oh you know we see holes
in this game right which is all [ __ ]
but yeah i just you just don't want the
chat i don't want anything i want
nothing i don't want to give them
nothing yeah yeah because i always knew
this was coming so i was alright planet
plot your way well you and i talked on
instagram yeah 2014. yeah yeah and we
were times like when am i gonna see you
bro yeah but hey i said give me my time
let me work yeah i've been working man
i've been working well i pay attention i
pay attention to dudes you shine thank
you sir outside you know i know guys who
are coming you know i know guys are
coming up but i knew you had been
thinking about mma and i had been a fan
of you as a kickboxer yeah i've been
working about it well i'm always
fascinated by elite specialists that
make their way into mma because i'm
always like oh how's this gonna
translate is it i think that it seems
harder
it seems harder for a lot of grapplers
who don't have a background striking i
mean i think grappling can be the most
important thing in mma because if you
can't stop a guy from taking you down
you're going to lose
but
you have to start every fight on your
feet and when you see a guy who doesn't
have good striking fight a guy who has
elite striking like a good example this
past weekend was kevin lee versus gregor
gillespie yeah gregory gillespie is a
[ __ ] fantastic wrestler elite
wrestler and kevin lee is a better
striker and you see that every fight and
kevin lee has a wrestling background too
so it's no picnic taking that guy down
but you see when a guy's a better
striker has more weapons and then gregor
gets high kicked it's a different kind
of feel and also one thing
eugene and andre
my arresting coach that alluded to is
people forget
the takedowns the wrestling starts way
before the clinch
starts way before you get taken down
away before you engage it's all about
positioning
foot positioning it's all about distance
control so once you have that and you
understand the the principles of that
your wrestling becomes easy like i might
have i don't know if it's the highest
takedown defense percentage in the ufc's
middle school
good it's i it's high but
and there's i mean the only time was in
my second fight when the guy
in the third round
i didn't break the grip and he sucked my
leg in immediately after because i
normally rumor andre he just kind of
told me what to do like okay ever since
that in training no one ever gets that
on me or really really gets that on me
so i
i'm always improving man like i said
even right now fomo i feel like fear of
missing out because i see everyone
dreaming
or fear of missing out that's uh yeah
it's an acronym yeah that's what the
kids are saying yeah i know the kids say
it but i never bothered looking at what
it means it's fear of missing out so
like oh my i see like on the group chat
what the team is doing and i see them
working the 10 am score shots at the
table squad where they're at
and you start feeling it like yeah
yeah 100 yeah especially like
just the young guys coming up you know i
see it and i'm not stupid man i know the
target's on my back it's easy to get
this but it's hard to keep it so
yeah i want to make sure i'm i want to
do what demetrius did i want to do what
silva did you know i want to be one of
those guys who just racks it up get all
the infinity stones
all the gems now what happens if they
over run the outside of this thing with
gems give me a new belt
yeah they used to give you a new belt
every time i know i'll stop putting
these ones all the gems on these bits
like guys like steep a stipend has a
[ __ ] little belt yeah would've been cool
every time i might i'm i'm sure i can
buy some of them you know
talk to somebody yeah yeah it's uh
what'd you think about the bmf belt um
yeah it's a touchy subject i felt like i
fee well i like the idea you know the
fact that nate diaz you know he ain't no
west coast gangster you know and yeah
you know from miami you know whatever
they should have kept that between them
the company didn't have to get involved
he didn't have to get involved to like
try and solidify this but what it was
was they needed a
title for the msg card because kobe and
usman and what
happened but look at this misha tate
versus holly holm was the co-main event
as a title fight for diaz uh mcgregor
one right so you know that fight itself
would have been fine without the belt
without the rock with all that kind of
stuff but it happened
and yeah it's cool what's going to
happen now is he going to defend it
because even the ego in me is like
[Laughter]
there's no point because are they going
to defend the belt are they going to i
don't know yeah well i feel like maz
vidal's championship cal i might put
some [ __ ] spinners on this now and
then do like john cena they call this
the freestyle belt
you know
like yeah i i you know i i see what he's
saying but
i feel like moz vidal is world champion
[ __ ] 100 100 i've been a fan of that
guy since yeah way back
everyone's just finding out now all
these guys oh street jesus i'm like well
i'm not a hipster like i knew him before
he was cool man you know i want to be
that guy but i'm i like his resurrection
i like the fact that he rebranded
himself because you have to do that i
see it in movies i see actors do it
entertainment you rebrand yourself new
package and then boom and also you know
what's happening with him
he said he went away he did this reality
show yeah i watched it but he said he
went away and had time to himself
yeah but what happened was he was on
this reality show and dan lambert said
it was terrible a terrible experience
was by himself all day no phone he had
to go into the village to get food
there's no [ __ ] food like rose island
i forget somewhere in south america but
the experience was it was several months
and it was a disaster and he didn't like
it at all and and then it
forced him to think about where he's at
where he could be
and one of the things he was saying is
like all these split decisions and he
was thinking like why you know why did
it go that way instead of the other way
like why did i lose that fight instead
of win it because there's a lot of them
that are really close yeah and he was
thinking
maybe i could just do a little bit more
and won that fight and then he said why
am i thinking like a [ __ ] peasant he
goes why don't i just knock that
[ __ ] out and then and so that
shift in his mentality change and then
all sudden he murks donald cerrone murks
darren till merks ben askren beats the
[ __ ] out of nate diaz like he's a
different person now and now he's what
he could have been yeah he is potential
realized like he's a rebirth he's at a
hundred percent he's at a hundred
percent right now
you get in the cage with that guy he's
even thinking about boxing with canelo
yes man crazy yes
it was interesting
he's got them all i mean his thought is
like hey man i i can do more than conor
mcgregor did and i'm not going to fade
yeah yeah
he can and i think because i watch the
fight again it's different when you
watch it live when i was watching it
live i saw diaz coming back and he was
in the third round and i was swinging
towards diaz like oh maybe he won that
round but i watched it back and i'm like
nah he had all three yeah and diaz was
like i said he was coming back but on
the skull cards
yeah i think he he already had it in a
couple of those rounds you could make an
argument for ten eights yeah he beat the
[ __ ] out of diaz in
i think he hit him in the gut and diaz
tactical move vent move just dropped
down mm-hmm just dropped down so he's
like hi come on my god because yeah he
probably got hurt to the body yeah i
heard one of them 16 the right right
body kick
it's slippery diaz try to block it on
and it just went right underneath yeah
and the thing i hate as well inspiring
is when you kick the elbow you ever
tried that
so yeah i broke my foot doing that
yeah yeah [ __ ] my foot i cracked the
door
tip of the elbow so hard and the top of
your foot is so soft it takes a real
skill like darren till has it as well
where they can sneak it underneath yeah
it's a different angle eugene taught me
how to do it so
yeah i love it i love it's one of my
moves i hit them to virus with it as
well before i sweat them yeah you have
to learn how to sweep like just right
underneath you got your eye on kill now
it's till now yeah
you know like an interesting guy i saw
him last year on the press conference
leading up to the bronson fight i
haven't said look i can't wait to do it
man i know one day we'll clash and it's
just because of the styles yeah like
styles make fights yeah you know and
he's got a style that i like
very basic but when i say basic i don't
mean that with due respect with
disrespect right i say he's got strong
basics he's a stout he's a southpaw
he's a nice straight left nice body kick
curves the left he knows how to change
it up and then the clinch as well when
he gets close i like what he did with um
gasoline yeah he played the distance
game well you know i learned it in the
third round i kind of learned it in the
fight but gasoline was doing something
to get close
right after the fight me and eugene
wants to fight like [ __ ] that's what he
did that's how we got so close and we
knew already but it was hard to call it
in the fight because we were too focused
on other things but i think
automatically through muscle memory i
was able to
take that distance away from him in the
fight and then from the third round but
for first i think for the first round
and some of the second round he was able
to like use it's a little hop step
everyone knows it now it's a little
upset he'd jab me jab me put it in my
face it's like a little
so you're calculating his movement yeah
i'm not doing it this way i'm doing it
like internal muscle memory right memory
it's your memory of fights and sparring
and knowing what you can do versus
knowing what you see him doing yeah and
just like it's like a dance so he comes
up it's super hard to explain to people
they don't understand why you look at a
guy and you're like listen to me that
guy's gonna [ __ ] that guy up and people
go what are you talking about mike
listen to me that guy's gonna like when
anderson silva first fought chris lieben
yeah i remember the odds were like real
close and i pulled a friend of mine
aside and said bet the house
bet the house on anderson he goes are
you serious i go bet the house i go bet
the house yeah i go this guy's an an
assassin this is a different thing
you're seeing a different thing i'm
telling you this is of this is one of
the rare
the [ __ ] sky has to fall for him to
lose
no one knew that's the thing no one knew
who he was until
that happened but i'd watch all those
caged warriors [ __ ] yeah when he was
standing in front of jorge rivera
letting him punch him in the face he
just rolling with just rolling with it
as well people don't understand this
like and they said
ah [ __ ] casuals it said yes i like it
and a lot of experts as well have casual
brains because they're like
israel has no knockout power because he
hit henderson silva in the face clean
i'm like you don't understand this
anderson is playing a game where me and
him are playing this game so
when i hit him i didn't hit him clean
i'm not trying to hit him where he is
i'm trying to hit him where he's gonna
be
but then he knows that as well so
he'd anticipate that and then pause
the distance is just right so it just
nicks him there's a time i kicked him in
the face and i slowed it down on my
instagram just went and just like my toe
literally you see my toes they're ugly
as [ __ ] like it just nicked the top lip
and i went she's glass because i felt it
yeah
and we're playing this game but like
literally i was trying to hit him where
he's gonna be but then he'd pause and
then the punch would just
so it looked cool yeah it looked like i
was like i didn't hit him clean right
like he just we're playing this game and
people don't understand people who've
never fought they don't understand that
game you're playing
yeah it was beautiful man i love that
fight people was like too it was boring
i was like [ __ ] i was iconic man that
was a i wish he had left after that
fight man because i wanted to be the one
the people are silly yeah that was that
was a great fight yeah but that's it's
just people that don't have an
appreciation for movement and like what
it takes what it takes people don't know
[ __ ] about mma no most people don't know
[ __ ] about everything exactly yeah i
mean there's a lot of people out there
that are experts
don't know [ __ ] about what they're
talking about the thing about anderson
and you is god damn i would have loved
to see that fight when anderson was 10
years younger and you're you are where
you're at right now i'll tell you how it
goes how's it go
same way it went you know why why he's
never had someone do to him what he's
done to people because what i was doing
to him
making him jump making him do whenever
he did this
that's all for gazey that's all like oh
you made it
i i've used it a few times you know what
it means it's an interesting term it was
uh there was a limousine company in new
york and they started writing bad checks
and uh so the those checks became fugazi
checks it's fake
so was that italian yeah yeah
it's it was a it was a limousine company
called fugazi limousine
so it's not a real word no well it is it
became an expression it just became an
expression
yeah yeah so this company started
writing bad checks so anytime that
something's fake it's for gazing oh yeah
learn something new every day like fomo
yeah
but like yeah so whenever i'd like faint
him or make him jump or make him react
you know like i got you he'd like
right trapping hands kung fu 52 blocks
right but
really good fighters great fighters but
never an elite kickboxer yeah never an
elite world-class kickboxer like a world
championship caliber fighter like
yourself
not well not a kickboxer but definitely
some like i said good fighters but
the guys all the guys that he beat of
that era they couldn't last in this era
it's a different time now the game has
changed the game keeps evolving and it
like
how do i say it's not disrespect but
it's just it's it's if you had me and my
prime right now well i'm not even in my
prime kind of in it how old are you now
27 do you 30 i know i try you look good
i think you said likewise likewise
likewise but um yeah it's just pretty
much the game of inches a game of fake a
game of gotcha right and i do that
better than him yeah i feel that and
dude this is the guy i've loved and i've
you know [ __ ]
gagged and [ __ ] about him the whole
[ __ ] career like he's a [ __ ] i use
wrong words yes
play fast forward
but uh like i know he's literally like
i've fanboyed over the guy his whole
career and i've studied him i knew what
he was gonna do before he do it like
when he tripped me i was getting up in
my head i was like okay here come that
flying knee and then whoop i did like
literally i pressed eject i was like get
the [ __ ] out of dodge straight away
honestly i was like i'm not and then
he's he just huffed the cage like at one
point even when i hit him in the tummy
oh no i hit him in the tummy and he he
touched me in the coming and i was like
he goes let me try i was like no
you didn't catch that or even when i at
one point when he put his hands down and
not like we're playing that game and
just went
i went stop doing that i threw my hands
up let's stop doing that there's no one
on this [ __ ] planet if you put your
hands there and chin up then i'll tell
you stop doing that but no hands down
shutting up keep doing that but for
whatever reason
i said stop doing that and i i don't
know why i said that that's why that's a
question i have to answer like after i
retire and see because people are like
oh did you hold back on anderson i'm
like [ __ ] no i was i rocked him in the
first round and if i had
deadened him
i was trying to i was trying to win but
yeah
i i still have love for the guy and i
respect the guy he might not feel the
same but he's some he's a guy that does
i think he does and he told me like in
the like he let me know what to do he
told me like i said don't lose focus and
that's why even right now like i said
fomo i'm like
you know all this [ __ ] is cool this
victory tour you know raiding this [ __ ]
around it's nice but
i want to work yeah yeah that's the
attitude that makes champions 100 man
was it weird being across the cage from
him knowing him like only one more one
moment there was one moment
and it was in the third round and he
went to the he's like come on puts his
back against the fence that's what he
did to bisping and he front kicked him
in the face he's like come on come on
it's okay and then like kind of sat
there and at one point i was just stood
there i was like i'm gonna wait two and
it was probably like seven seconds but
there's a split second in there that i
was just like
holy [ __ ]
i'm fighting and it's in silver
[Laughter]
now [ __ ] off now this is my time in my
back and i was like nice right here then
he came to the center of the cage and
then we kept it going but like it right
there yeah
this right here is going to live forever
god damn that picture look at that
picture i'm done fighting with what i'm
gonna do in this game oh my god it's for
moments like this [ __ ] the belt it's
iconic moments that you know like ali
over um sunny listen yeah yeah pictures
got that at home framed signed by
muhammad ali wow yeah see [ __ ] like that
i'll sign this with someone sometime and
then
it's gonna be framed honestly it's so
beautiful man this is rock lee even
something like this there's some
synchronicities that happened so this is
from this anime
the first fight i watched in this can
google this pull it up james
um what is it uh rock lee versus gara
g-a-a-r-a this is episode 46 of naruto
and it was the first fight i ever
watched that got me into the series
and what is this anime series naruto
i've only seen it online it takes too
long it's a 720 episode [ __ ] yeah 720
episodes yeah so he said this bit right
here he takes the weight off
he takes the weight off oh you can watch
the highlights and then literally
there's some heavy ass weights but he
[ __ ] up gara but i did the stance rock
lee normally does
i did the stance that he normally does
in the weins and anderson stood there
like gaara but he probably doesn't even
know
what that is well he just stood there
like this and [ __ ] like that it's a tied
you to fight it just like when life
imitates art without even trying you
know what i mean and i edited it i got
some guys you know shout out to craft
and blackberry fx they edited it for me
to make it look the same as this but
literally
yeah [ __ ] like this jazzes me up man i'm
geeking out right now
[ __ ] nerd
shout out to john jones are you sorry
do you call you nerd yeah i know oh my
feelings
dirt is not negative man of course i
mean i'll take it i'm gonna figure it
out i got nunchuck skills bow hunting
skills
all that there's nothing wrong with
being a nerd man i mean nerds run the
world [ __ ] yeah elon yeah nerds around
the [ __ ] world you're telling kids
man like don't peek in high school man
especially the nerds
i told them i've spoken to some some
schools now and i just tell them like
look
and new zealand's got the highest you
suicide rate in the world and it's
because a lot of these kids like
literally yeah they think
you think this is going to be forever
like whatever they're feeling the
depression being bullied being [ __ ]
with and it's different now because of
all this [ __ ] yeah likes caught you know
depression and whatnot social media
people attacking you and i just tell
them like look it's going to be fine
this isn't forever
at the end of the day they will peak now
like when i go back
to where i grew up in rotorua when i see
some of the kids they used to [ __ ] with
me
i'm like i'm scared of you right like
literally even when i close my eyes now
because i was i i had a late growth
spurt i can see them i visualize them
and they i still see them as bigger than
me but when i go back they're like
short and dumpy and got like five
different kids to three different baby
mamas and working at the same job for
the last 12 years and i'm just like
man you were in the first 15 rugby team
you were the man i thought you was the
man
but now i'm the man but i never feel any
kind of aware of it i don't feel only
two of them ever apologize but i don't
feel like because i'm petty you know i
got chips and dips on my shoulder i'm
that guy but i don't feel the type of
way where i have to like [ __ ] on them
because i understand kids are cruel kids
are dumb and i see at this day and age i
see it like they don't even know what
they're doing while they're doing it
they just [ __ ] angry little chimps
with hormones and they don't know what's
happening
instruction i would have told myself
don't think with your penis that's the
best advice i'll give young man because
no one tells them that no one yeah jerk
off first then things that's right no
what's this no not november [ __ ] oh
that's nonsense what that's a good way
to make it i lost on the first day
mistakes
three times
oh call that man i'm blessing man
exactly all that tantric [ __ ] gotta let
it go try to keep it inside their body
that's nonsense because then it's aged
jizz
like if you if you haven't [ __ ] after
a while when you just look at it yeah
it's like whiskey yeah dried age
i'm not gonna trick this
i know i feel bad about drinking it now
it's all right
yeah what is that no nut november get
out of here that's a good way to stay
confused yeah you're gonna make a lot of
bad choices yes yeah how many times have
guys made bad choices i was trying to
explain this to a woman she was saying
that men are [ __ ] and they pretend
to be someone so just so they can [ __ ] a
girl and then after they [ __ ] a girl
then you see who they really are listen
they don't even know who the [ __ ] they
are when a guy's telling you they're in
love with you
they mean that in that moment and then
they come and then they're like
what what did i do i got to get out of
here yeah like they're not it's not that
they're being deceptive to you they're
being deceived as well yeah i had a
whole bit about it that when you have a
bone
your bit you you are like in the back
seat of a very long bus
and there's another dude driving the bus
like where the [ __ ] is he going like
yeah you're watching your life take
place through a windshield 50 feet away
from you that's what it's like for me
don't do it man yeah if you come you
jerk off first and you go out with a
girl if you really enjoy your company
yeah
november yeah wait who won this thing by
the way the sober october we didn't have
a championship this year we all we did
just for friends yeah we just had a
thing where you had to do 10 classes and
read 500 pages of any books okay we just
decided that's cool see that's something
you can get behind yeah last year was
too crazy we're doing cardio seven hours
a day
between tommy and um machine yeah yeah
because he was doing some crazy [ __ ] to
try and lose away yeah they were all
trying to lose weight and bert i told
him if he gets down to 205 he could have
the silver october belt to say hey
but uh what's he right now she's about 2
all you have 300. do is lose the weight
get the belt i mean i was like
i'm gonna go he goes like we're about
235 i go dude there's guys who fight in
the 205 pound division that way 235 on
tuesday and they fight on saturday and
they they weigh in on friday at 205. you
can do it you can do it but you know
just work on the burt bert's gonna burp
yeah it's a discipline issue
[Laughter]
so i think he's coming to new zealand as
well he's already using the
my man tony angelo said if you want to
come through he can suss it out okay
yeah now he's looking forward to it but
he said like get in contact with him i
was like i don't know what i'm gonna do
do a gig and then take a few days and go
hunting bro you would love it man even
if you take your kids and just like
there's a lodge out there oh yeah it's
really expensive but i'm sure for you
they'll they'll cut you out okay yeah
easy yeah that's nice spot and they'll
take you to one of these ranches where
you know you can get you you can either
like my advice go with eugene i won't
even come like go eugene he knows like
some [ __ ] and he knows the skills as
well or you can go to these ranches
where they have it for you where you can
get one of those like a big red yeah
like my first time i shot one dead was a
big red and i remember like for downwind
we tracked it took ages and you're
surprised how the guy who owns the land
old man but he was [ __ ] kicking our
ass man like me and usually
but he's just like a mountain goat just
tracking trekking they're used to hiking
it's nothing to do it every day yeah and
then i get there and then we like takes
about maybe 10 minutes because they're
all there in the herd yeah feasting and
then we like flanked it properly we're
not was it downwind we're upwind away
from it that's the one you don't want
them to smell it you want to be downwind
so that one's coming to you yeah so they
can't smell us yeah yeah and then i
remember like hit it
boom right there you hit it with a rifle
yeah rifle yeah yeah i don't know how to
use a bow yet yeah but then yeah yeah
cameron yeah yeah cameron said he wanted
cameras yeah he said wait in time in
time any time i want to fight first
oh man but then she dropped right there
darren dead and then i went up there and
me and my boy rod as well my tattooist
he shows me how to like section it up
and then there's a slinky in there like
that's we call that um the baby so you
take that out slanky yeah it's like the
baby that the infant that's in there oh
you've shot a female yeah female yeah so
she dropped there literally yeah right
there i think they call it slinky
because of the way it moves i'm assuming
so jesus yeah so
so you dispose of that because the pig's
gonna eat it it's gonna go back to the
earth all that kind of stuff that was
the first day and that was my big red
and the next day
we're going we're on the [ __ ] what do
you call the atv and then i don't know
where we see two fallows the smaller
ones and they're up on the ridge and
then my coach doug doug vine he's a k1
champion as well from vegas why not and
then i shot it
and i didn't hit this one that's clean
so then like we have to trek all the way
up mm-hmm taunt like you know all this
kind of [ __ ] you know what do you call
him a stinger needle
yeah [ __ ] annoying and then get up to
it and see it trying to like
oh the vegas is going to hate me for
this
but then i was like oh [ __ ] okay and
then you got to finish it off yeah i
have to you know do the right thing so i
get the rifle right i'm there i'm
looking at it and then
i'm looking through the scope and then
doug's like
this is up after about 30 seconds you
all right i was like yeah hold up just
have to
i was like you're not scared i'm like
nah
but then i realized the shit's [ __ ]
two feet in front of me i'm using the
scope oh you couldn't see it
oh yeah
yeah and that was it she was done you
couldn't find anything and then yeah
scopes are weird yeah too close you're
all [ __ ] up
like a brain fart moment because i was
just used to using the scope so i'm like
how the [ __ ] you're using the scope when
the thing's right there in front of you
so i just hit it boom point blank dead i
had to do the same thing with the first
deer shot stop suffering but then one
thing i really enjoyed was afterwards
when you have to section it right there
and this is the thing man if you can't
my personal philosophy is if you can't
hunt if you can't kill what you eat
don't eat meat don't touch it because
you don't understand where it comes from
and eventually one day kind of like you
what you have now you have your own
operation i want to have my own
operation i want to have
my own like
land my own property where i can just
like bang bang bang yeah freezer stock
it up right pigs
organic meat yeah yeah and it's
different man it's a lot different
especially when you have to section it
yourself
this fallout section myself the big one
i gave to my butcher friend to make like
garlic sausages and salami all that
stuff beautiful
and then
yeah rod taught me how to section the
you know what you use your your hands
wet you put it through the skin and it
acts like a knife and it's easy to
separate the soft tissue it's actually a
good technique
and yeah it was fun but it's been about
two years now since i've been back in
the bush because you know the nutrition
though so much stronger it's so good for
athletes for someone like yourself oh my
god that that fallow deer and stag that
nutrition is as good as it gets yeah
wild animals i think even i think was
before the um bronson fight
because
long story but like after my debut
i'll go back to this but like pretty
much the the brunson fight before it was
when i realized how you eat affects how
you think and how you feel your mental
health no sure because beforehand
before the fight before i couldn't wait
i was eating like [ __ ]
like literally just because you know i
cut way easy so i'm just eating
everything what not and throughout that
camp i was getting like i hurt myself as
well remember i i mentioned at the first
five press conference and then i had to
take a whole week off training this is
like five weeks out and i had to make
the call like [ __ ] we're gonna pull from
this fight so we don't leave it too late
so they can find a replacement or
take a whole week off come back monday
and then see how we feel
and then doing that i ate right i ate
proper
you know i was a little bit like
depressed and [ __ ] like that because of
what i was eating already but that week
transitioned everything just because the
way i was eating and the way i looked
after my body and then when i got back
to camp
boom and i realized through that camp
and also reading charlemagne's book as
well the shook ones oh yeah it kind of
helped me i listened to it yeah i
listened to it too
yeah well that's a good one to listen to
too because it's read by him yeah he's
funny interesting orientation yeah and
the way he reads it he's funny because i
listen to brilliant idiots as well yeah
he's honest yeah he's on i mean like for
a guy like him to talk about being
[ __ ] up with anxiety it's like people
are like what you you're the guy who
talks about crazy [ __ ] nah people don't
understand man like even my boy chance
he's with me right now you know like for
me i like to cause i'm on this
journey now i like to take those that
came up with me i bring them on this
journey like i went to dubai i brought
my brother with me so i can inspire him
i went to nigeria i brought abe with me
you know because he's a nigerian
i told him after this trip like be
careful because you're gonna you know
holiday blues
you know like when you come back from a
holiday you feel like oh yeah everyone
all these instagram hosts post take me
back you know with their bikini shots
and whatnot
i told him i when you get back home
you're going to feel it and i know
because i've experienced it as well
after my ufc debut
i
literally my after party was three hours
of just
hi nice to meet you hi at one point i
literally went to go hide somewhere and
some guy found me he's like bro you all
right what are you doing i'm like i'm
good i'm just chilling i'm just taking
five minutes alone it's like oh yeah
it's like now y'all understand day and
just sat next to me i'm just like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
alone means you not being here
[ __ ] and then after i got home
like you know got a bonus
got a nice check from the ufc
and then got depressed
and i'm just like what's the feeling
yeah like i'm home alone with my own
thoughts and i was like what the [ __ ] i
didn't get that i didn't understand this
so i even just because of everything
that was happening i started seeing the
therapist straight away just because i
felt like no one teaches you how to be
famous there's no [ __ ] book about
this and i've seen a lot of people
athletes movies singers rappers rise and
fall and i'm not gonna be one of those
people good for you
but then i went to a therapist from
october from february to october just to
kind of like
learn some tools to help me with this
and then so after my first fight it
happened my second fight it happened my
third fight brad tara's fight main event
[ __ ] all the stimulus it's like
coffee you drink coffee and then you get
all the stimulus you hype and you come
off it crash yeah i equivoc i i equate
it to the same thing
and then
those tools that i got from my therapist
really helped me just kind of like
navigate back so new york was the first
fight i got back to my house and i was
like right boom i know how to attack
this i know what's gonna happen and i
was anticipating because beforehand
i didn't anticipate the um the hype that
was going to happen the wave
after the fight like after this fight i
already know what's happened like i knew
it was going to be like
more than everything i've done in the
ufc already so i braced for it and i
prepared myself and i had the right
people and the right tools to help me
ease back into my regular routine so i
went back home it was just easy what was
the feeling of depression because
obviously you had this spectacular
result you you won yeah and then but
what what was it what was the feeling
like what was bothering you if i think
about in my debut when i got back home
sit down
um
[Music]
it was just like
i don't know and that's not i hate trust
me i love [ __ ] the perks [ __ ] fame i
don't like being famous but i love the
perks a lot of perks
but like when you get back home and i'm
with that's why i like hanging out with
my dogs and my cat because they don't
say anything i can just be i can just
exist with them i don't have to
entertain them i don't have to talk
right contrary to popular belief i'm not
always extroverted i'm a cuss baby i'm a
crab lion cancer leo a crab lion cancer
in the leo yeah
but like i can go you know both ways you
know hard soft right like a sammy chop
but you know
but like yeah so i can when i'm home by
myself i'm just very
reserved i like to build my own thoughts
i like to be in my own space yeah like
what jorge had to do in panama or
wherever he was yeah and the feeling was
just not it's almost i've heard of
impostor syndrome mm-hmm
i i'm not sure if i'm saying it if i'm
using it right but i don't know i want i
don't want to say that's what i had
but like you almost feel like you don't
you don't belong yeah like i don't
belong i don't deserve this everybody i
think everybody has that yeah so when i
so i had to go through that for my first
flight my second flight my third fight
and like i said it wasn't until the
brunson fight i just decided to [ __ ]
own it because in new york yeah there's
this clip on youtube of this guy
he's walking around times square normal
just chilling no one pays attention to
him
and then he goes to
he goes uh comes back at night time and
then he's hired like security camera
crew he dresses the part and he's
walking around trying square he's just a
regular dude like a youtube content
creator
and then
everyone's starting to like who's this
what's this guy oh oh can i take a photo
yeah cool take a photo yeah cool and
then like the camera guy goes up to
random people and goes like so how do
you know his name is brian how do you
know brian how do you and they're like
uh i i saw him in spider-man you know
yeah i think it was pretty good you know
and then let's the guy will go to
another guy you know so what do you
think about his last album
like oh
i mean i didn't hear the whole thing but
i heard a single on the radio and people
just lying through their teeth
lying through their teeth about who the
[ __ ] this guy is when they don't even
know who he was right i experienced that
at deja vu [ __ ] crazy in times square
in new york madison square garden i
experienced that in times square like
literally shooting for my brand engage
shooting some shots for them so there's
embedded crew around me micro around me
and i'm not even trying and at one point
i kind of just cuz i i'm always noticing
everything around me and i see people
like some people recognize where i was
and then i saw people like and i can
hear them like who's he and the same
person will come hey man big fan yo can
i grab a pic i'm just like all right
take a pic and the next person like you
said hi can i get a picture and just
take a picture and they don't know who
the [ __ ] i am they just know somebody
likes you exactly they just oh he's
famous yeah boom and they just want to
get that shine so
[ __ ] like that kind of humbles you and
lets you know you can get caught up in
all that [ __ ] man i talk about hype a
lot and i'm like [ __ ] it just own it new
york is when i decided like i'm not
gonna feel like i don't belong just own
it this is my life now well i think what
you're doing is you're taking the
mentality of a high-level striker and
you're applying it to fame because you
don't want to get caught in traps
you unders you want to see all the
pitfalls like if you're your chin is up
you drop your hand if you you have a
tendency that someone can exploit you
got to go oh make sure i mix this up
maybe show them different moves
you you don't want to get caught in
traps yeah i don't want to get caught
never yeah that's but that is also what
happens with fame you get caught in your
own traps you set your own traps yeah i
know i make my own mistakes i won't
crash into a pregnant lady bob make my
own mistakes
sorry i'm taking all the shots
come get it well when you and him
started going after it when jon jones
started going after it on instagram i
was like oh no let it be known he
started it yes he started it why did he
start it i don't know
i think i'm the freshman i'm the guy
that he wishes he was and he's a fan
trust me he's a fan he's my biggest fan
and i think he sees himself
you know like man i could have been that
cool you know if i didn't [ __ ] all this
up and he sees me like the new freshman
getting all the shine getting all the
hype well he's still the champ he is and
he's still undefeated but not really no
really
he was just trying yeah you know i don't
i mean matt hamill's probably broke yeah
you know what i'm saying i mean he
hasn't fought in forever yeah you know i
get it yeah he just wanted another he's
undefeated he's a guy i think i first
watched him fight because i was a fan it
was uh ufc 94
penn versus gsp2 and he fought stephanie
yeah and just hit him with some stuff
hillary with that spinning elbow hit him
with that double overhook lateral draw
who the [ __ ] this guy yeah you know
and
you know the comparisons were always
going to be there like with him and oh
this is silva with wrestling then when i
came on the scene oh it says jones a
better striking i'm like
i and i said it from the get-go i will
outgrow those those comparisons i was
like oh they're going to forget about
this so now they're not comparing us
they're saying ooh let's watch them
fight yeah i like the fight i said this
is july
um
after the i think it was the mma awards
i was in my hotel room
and
allegedly i might have been stoned but
allegedly i was [ __ ] stoned and i was
looking across and i could see raider
stadium being built
and i was like
for whatever reason just decided that's
where it's going to happen it's such a
[ __ ] crazy fight the way it's going
to happen it's just
boom let him go to heavyweight i'll drag
him back down i'll drag him back down
and i said like 2021 is the time because
i don't want to disrespect the game i'm
not going to hold up the division the
division be held up long enough by
robert [ __ ] being sick and being
injured and you know romero not making
winning all this [ __ ] i'm like let me do
what silva did which was honor the
[ __ ] code and actually be a champion
and defend the belt so i'm going to do
that i've done it once against robert
whitaker double interim champ so i'm
going to do it again there's killers out
there i even saw canon here in the
weekend and he's a [ __ ] beautiful
dude man such a nice guy he's a very sad
what's up brother how you doing
exactly he's the dark horse he's the
dark one everyone thinks romero is
everyone thinks koster is the one nah he
is the guy i'm like i'm stalking him
i've been watching the man he's another
guy that's made a shift over the last
year and a half or so jared's made a
shift where he's just become more and
more serious more and more dangerous and
you watch him when he took out anderson
silva when he [ __ ] his leg up be like
jesus like yeah he's on on a mission
he's on a mission i see him man i'm not
slipping he'll never catch me slipping
unless i slip him and i rip him he's got
fantastic genetics too and that guy's a
tank see i saw when he was fighting this
guy a heavyweight he was heavyweight
yeah he walked him down with his hands
down yeah heavyweight yeah he's always
185 shredded yeah it's crazy good man
go all the way from heavyweight to 185
that's
[ __ ] phenomenal i think roy nelson
should have done it to be honest
what do you think about that kid edmund
chabazian
um i saw his fight i didn't know who he
was until um i think it was tim i'm
saying his last name right right yeah
yeah
tell him what's his name um tim told me
like oh [ __ ] then i rewatched the fight
and i saw oh did i see your life i can't
remember dude he's 21 years and he hit
brad tavares with a head kick and that
kind of got my attention like oh [ __ ]
who's this kid
um he starched him with that right hand
and you know that's what i mean like
he's at 185 he's 21 yeah he's on the
come up yeah he just beat i played with
brad for five rounds he starts him in
one round you know
i'm not taking that likely yeah i look
at that kid
eventually when when he comes up you
know i'm sure i'll see him at some point
but that's what i mean i need to get
back to work don't get me wrong i
understand i'm working yeah i'm working
but like i want to you know you know the
phone i feel oh yeah yeah what's that as
well if i don't train that is the thing
of pressure that is the thing of
pressure of being a champion you know
i'll never forget when
bj penn choked out
matt hughes to win the title in 170. and
i was interviewing matt in the in the
octagon he was real honest about it goes
i'm going to be honest with you this is
a relief
it was the pressure the pressure of all
these guys coming after me for so long
he goes i'm glad it's off my shoulder
they're not used to it and that's why i
said that about robert on i said on
record like i said he's not used to this
pressure is an acquired taste it's an
acquired taste and not everyone likes it
it's like caviar or egusi or yeah you
know
exactly people don't understand it and
for me
before the ufc there's a hike you know i
jump in the ufc do my work hype hype
hype all the way through yeah and i said
i've been chopping this pressure for
breakfast lunch and dinner it's easy to
me the guy's been away the whole time
i've been running through the [ __ ]
division the time i've been you know
like staking my claim as a [ __ ] champ
and he's not used to this pressure and
your comeback fight you want to come up
in the biggest show against me
i wouldn't even if i was a coach
16 months is too long to put a guy
against me and i said he's not going to
be used to it he said oh you know i
don't care you know this israel is not
as good as he thinks he is i was like
all right watch this
well the thing about the ufc is you
don't get tuned up fights nah they don't
exist that's why i said i'm gonna i'm
gonna come here ready because i know
they're gonna put me in the deep end
they're gonna put me against the guy so
that's why me and eugene had the plan
like we got to be ready for everyone
yeah
to be honest i'm glad it happened the
way it happened i'm glad i didn't rush
and people were like oh
well you're not the youngest champion
you have seen history you mean i'm like
i didn't want to be it doesn't matter
because if not like i'm glad all this
[ __ ] happened to me not when i was 23 or
24 because i would have [ __ ] up don't
weigh worse [ __ ] you know but i'm happy
that i matured i had my metamorphosis
when i was 28. and that's when a shift
happened for me that's when i became
china helped a lot as well like being
away from my comfort zone being in the
mainland and
excuse me hey my man
like china helped me get ready for all
this because being a big black man in
the mainland they don't really see
people like us all the time
fighting in my first stadium show in
china in front of 40 000 people
being mobbed in china all that stuff i
just used as rep so i was like okay this
is all preparing me for this this is all
preparing me for the big time so when
this time comes i got to be ready and i
got to roll out do you have a very wise
way of looking at the future and i think
that's what led you to getting therapy
when you started feeling a little weird
after your first fight i mean that's a
very intelligent that to to seek help to
try to figure out okay there's got to be
a good way to handle this and i need
tools yeah and there's a stigma around
it as well even when i mentioned i think
i put it up i put my um on my instagram
story
after um
my win against robert whitaker i went to
a therapist that monday the session was
supposed to last maybe an hour and a
half we finished in 30 minutes because i
saw her two weeks beforehand the week of
the fight and then i saw her after the
fight and literally was like cool i
think we got what we needed all right
i'll see you if i need you again but
then people were like
oh
so brave you know you come out and you
know for people with mental illness and
oh my god hashtag
i'm like i'm not is it not everyone is
mentally ill but
everyone has to look after their mental
health yeah if you don't then you will
get sick just like your physical health
if you don't look after if i start
eating [ __ ] drinking all day i'll get
physically sick so if you don't look
after your mental health then you're
going to get mentally healed then
they're going to put you in a straight
jacket yes and all that you know yeah
you don't want that so for me i just
have to look after myself i don't want
to end up like
2007 brittany
you know
oh shaving yeah
that's a thing where you're dealing with
a young person and when you said about
that you're not the youngest ever champ
i don't think it's good i don't think
it's good to have that kind of un
unqualified success
not unqualified and you don't deserve it
but yeah unprecedented at a young age
like mike tyson like mike tyson he'll
talk openly about it man i mean now you
ever have you hung out with mike no i
was supposed to this week but he's busy
so another time well i look forward to
it dude let's do the hot box together
yeah
dude he's a nice guy man and he's he's
so philosophical about his past yeah and
the way he's he's he's very
this is garbage yeah garbage yeah i
don't even like to think about what i
was like
he doesn't like to even think about who
he was he doesn't like to work out yeah
because he doesn't want to bring that
ego back i think you see him with
francis in ghana when he's ripping oh
yeah
he's still got it i got it listen man
but apparently he's gonna train francis
yeah he said yeah that would be
interesting apparently gypsy king is
gonna do mma
i'd love to see it man if he could
actually like once he gets that first
leg kick he's gonna be yeah what the
[ __ ] have i done no you better well get
it before you get in the cage i'll say
that did you ever see shannon the canon
briggs talk about when he fought uh when
he fought in k1 i listened to that oh my
god he's like that first leg i was like
champ what is this
bar
i don't think he's dead i don't know i'm
gonna just take this and knock him out
he thought tom erickson big cat was a
big [ __ ] i'm a natural 290 pound
dude natural oh she's gigantic erickson
was huge that's a leg we have a guy
carlos albert like
beautiful like built [ __ ]
he kicks because he's samoan as well i
think yeah full samoan he kicks and man
you don't want a whole patch file if you
have to hold um vo2 max kickboxing for
him he can break arms man and i'm sure
he used to be a boxer he only just
learned how to kick and now i've been
watching him he's turning his hip over
he's also a former king of the ring
champ as well current king and ring
check but like literally he yeah bones
muscle and
you don't you don't want that i was at
beverly hills jiu jitsu way back in the
day in the 90s and i watched pedro hizzo
kick the back yeah he just
there it is
both of my legs glued together yeah
they're so big
even now even now still thick but he was
in my opinion the best heavyweight in in
the history of mma the best heavyweight
leg kicker wow he would throw leg kicks
and my one is everybody would call me
dunk oh yeah
i know what i used to like was his hip
oh yeah swing that head oh yeah it's a
different style dutch style yes but i
still i do mind
there's many types of leg kicks people
don't know mm-hmm like there's many
types of jabs
there's levels to this and he had this
one where he'd like swivel his hip like
he'd almost just like a barbie like take
his leg and just pop yeah
almost like a
low brazilian kick yeah almost like
did he did the question mark kick better
than anybody who's that globe
fought in k1 okay
go to um uh robin black's twitter page
from today he posted a global fatosa ko
globe i mean everybody knew the question
mark kick right you go up the middle and
then you go around this way to a head
kick but globe would go
up and down in this crazy way like his
hips swiveled he had it he had the
dexterity of that down
in in just this crazy way that very few
because like you would have your hands
up in a good position he would come over
your hands and drop down on your face
yeah at an angle i've done that before
inspiring just like this is years ago i
did i would say to who did you see it on
robin's page he retweeted it earlier
today
he retweeted his own [ __ ] which is
hilarious
whenever you do that it's like when
people at you in your own comment i'm
like
what's my page why you got to at me
i don't know it doesn't mean anything
but just [ __ ] pet peeves i'm 100
giving up on reading my ass
i don't i don't read a goddamn thing
that comes my way you're just just
spitting into the wind
come out once in a while like if fight
week is when i have time the best one
was new york new york i get there early
and this guy was already bugging me for
because you see like in the
notifications when you you scroll up i'm
like this guy again so i was like i got
time today boom
i went at him man and i was just some
fan some fan and he was like i was
saying you know hey israel i like
winning his dm's and i started going
back and forth with him and i screen
recorded the the the interaction and
then eventually after the fight i think
maybe about two weeks after i roasted
and posted him he changed his instagram
name
and the [ __ ] got reported i was like oh
one person
yeah like dana sometimes if i have if i
if i got time today i got time to like
jon jones same thing one day i just went
at him because he was just going back
and forth on twitter back he was going
fourth and i just kind of ignored him i
was living my life and like sometimes
two weeks ago i was just like you know
what hold my bear
well he's not coming he's not coming
after you unless you're a threat yeah
exactly there so no see watch the video
play the video
fatosa there it goes no no watch this
left kick man
and then he does the
[ __ ] i've seen that before on the k1
ultimate knockout highlights but watch
the the motion of the kick when robin
breaks it down sweat this
look at this watch this the final part
watch this [ __ ] right here watch this
come on son
come on who the [ __ ] does that
globe is the master of the question mark
kick to the point where they call it the
brazilian kick man i mean but he almost
did it different than a question mark
kick because essentially he was making
it look like he was throwing a body
roundhouse kick he wasn't like the real
question mark kick is like a front kick
that you turn into a round kick but
globby was throwing it like he was
throwing it to the body and then last
second look at this [ __ ]
right here this is my favorite part i
mean this is like a wet background
kyokushin yeah kyokushin look at this
come on man went over the garden
over the guard and just like better than
anybody at it better than anybody and
then
that [ __ ] yeah at the end finish off
wow
bobby had i mean he had a weird way of
moving his hips that you go man i don't
know how many people can [ __ ] move
their hips like that shakira yeah
never yeah this uh that was a i mean
it's sometimes someone that just
develops a way of doing a kick that's
like different than everybody else yeah
even even now like eugene likes to make
fun of me he's like you're getting old
i'm like why
he's like it takes me about a week for
my hips to warm up before the kick
starts to like happen the way it
normally should i'm like [ __ ] so he
goes back and forth with me on that but
i'm getting into i've been doing yoga
for a while i kind of slacked off a
little bit this camp but
off season i'm gonna get back into it
just because
i'm 30 now only
i don't really feel old though that's
the thing like you're supposed to
magically suddenly sneeze and blow your
back out and all this [ __ ] you're 40.
yeah okay is that when you're 40 should
start but everyone the only thing i've
noticed is just the hangovers take a
whole day now that's all
that's the only thing because like some
liquid iv yeah oh vegas but i had to ask
first because you know you saw that you
can't no no liquid iv is a drink oh yeah
yeah it's formulated
it's called liquid iv they just pour it
into water okay rehydrates you much
quicker is it like a brand yeah it's a
sponsor of the podcast
what is it like it hydrates you two to
three times faster than water alone
that's like drinking three bottles of
water yeah minerals yeah please thank
you yeah it's very smart scientific
concoction i will take that yeah that'll
help you
yeah i mean there's a lot of little
tricks you can do to get rid of the
hangovers glutathione is another one
glutathione is uh it's i've heard the
name yeah it's
i don't know what the exact term what
kind of molecule it is specifically but
it's in glutamine is it a what is
glutathione exactly glutathione but what
it does is it helps your body break down
alcohol at an accelerated rate yeah and
a lot of times people take it while
they're drinking or take uh homes over
yes just drink some more
yeah because the hangover
is just alcohol but i don't drink that
crazy though i'm not like an alcoholic
or nothing well dr carl hart explained
that to me yeah yeah he said that's why
what a hangover actually is is your
body's withdrawals from alcohol that's
why people say you know what's that
expression uh
something the dog that bit you was what
is that uh bite the hair the dog yes by
the hair the dog that bit you yes like
so when you're hungover you have an
extra like a bloody mary that's what
bloody mary's are for oh bite the hair
of the dog the hair of the dog not bite
the hair the dog
but the hair of the dog that bit you so
you don't want to the whole dog you just
want a little bit just like get you over
that hangover and that's what blood and
air is out yeah bloody mary's are like
just a little drink in the morning yeah
just a little just a little bit with
tomato juice and celery to pretend that
you're [ __ ] healthy at celery
mimosas at brunch i don't know how dudes
live in vegas and training yeah [ __ ] all
that last time i was there holy [ __ ] so
i was there in july
for eight days the first three days i
did my testing at the pi
i was training you know no drinking
nothing like that
and then the mma awards happened
the next five nights
[ __ ] me i was just one i just wanted to
leave man but you can't help it because
you just you're in there and then it's
just like oh yeah cool you want to come
to this club yeah we got vip yeah i will
hook you up
that's where jorge said he saw me at the
at the club shirtless it wasn't inside
it was outside there was no women around
me it was literally just people in the
next booth boy it just looks that way
and he kind of added a little flavor you
know of what i said but i didn't say all
i said was like i know you know joel's
your boy but i want to see him because
he's a bad [ __ ] and i said i
want to fight all the bad [ __ ]
of this of this era yeah he's one of
them so and he that's that he respected
that so respect to that but
i didn't say nothing about you know
legacy and life i don't fight him
i want to fight him i've called him out
and when he put that other video like
you know why are you hiding i'm like i'm
not hiding i want to [ __ ] fight you i
want that fight i love you i feel like
that's the fight right now i mean i
don't see anybody other i mean a rebound
rematch with whitaker is hard to sell
right now you starched him yes he's got
to come back and do something the that
is the fight
so i think yolo romero is a fighter
costa's got an injury he just had his
bicep repaired allegedly you don't
believe it
think you fake the surgery
sips tea
no but um i i just don't believe
anything after icarus man like after
seeing everyone like i don't believe no
one that documented me [ __ ] my
painting man out there with the diaz
brothers everybody on stage
yeah i met him yeah he's a cool [ __ ]
crazy dude man i like how he takes all
his pictures a little bit over here i
did one as well i put the bandana on and
i took it too i was like i see you ninja
[ __ ] but um
yeah uh i don't know like he can heal up
or whatever but give me your middle yeah
i said it i've said it i'll say it again
i'm not ducking no one i ain't [ __ ]
ducking nobody give me the fight yeah i
don't understand the idea that he's lost
all those fights so you can't have that
that's why
you talking dana please dana listen to
me that you can make that fight
everybody wants to see it 100
100 of the hardcore fans want to see it
all you have to do is show a yo romero
heart
i will do a countdown for that i don't
do those anymore i will do it for that
fight yeah i swear to god i look forward
to the challenge man i want that fight i
want to see it i want to see it because
he's got to find his neck he's a unique
traps
i want to find his name it's all it's
just
what's going right into his brain
i'm telling you my peruvian necktie is
tight now oh i thought i knew what it
was i thought i had it before because i
used to get it like maybe 30 of the time
yeah my man showed me some [ __ ] and he
also showed me because you see the
gaston fight do you know where that came
from peruvian necktie no it's connie
d'souza oh yeah yeah de souza invented
it i think he invented it because well
if he didn't invent it he [ __ ] nailed
it yeah and so it became to prove you
next time you name it beast
is one of the lost beasts yeah like i
used to love watching that guy fight
[ __ ] prove you a [ __ ] with a
big thick beard fought like a savage
tough as [ __ ]
tough as [ __ ] tony d'souza people forgot
it but they sleep on there's so many
great fighters from the old days they
get slept on but tony de souza is the
one yeah sort of like you know like the
the von flucho because jason von flu but
i think you got to rename that the os i
want to rename
i want to rename the peruvian once i do
what osp has been doing because even
like um
i think he invented the peruvian necktie
i think de sousa invented it yeah he's
credited as the modified guillotine
choke yeah i think he invented it what
it is is for people don't know what
we're talking about it's kind of like a
sideways guillotine where you throw the
leg over the head and the back it's nice
it looks cool man well it hurts like i
was doing it like this with this grip
and then homeboy misha showed me how to
get deep
and then hold it from here marcelo
garcia's style yeah yeah
yeah just throw the legs over and say
yeah that's tony tony de souza old
school yeah he figured it out man out
and it's all about that leg over the
head man once you got that leg over the
head i got a leg
heavy weight some heavy weight so when
you put that on the back of someone's
head and you go
yeah straight away that's a nice one a
bunch of people have got a tb doll
always got it before a few other guys
have got it yeah i saw cb dollars one
doberman i saw that one but there's um
like and in the gaslamp fight in the
last like 20 seconds i had a front
headlock on him and
i thought about going for a dash choke
but i knew eugene might yell at me so i
did it why would he yell at you
didn't want you to grab it
just because i i had the guillotine not
the triangle but it was slippery and
also i was already winning the striking
i don't want to end up like frank mario
when he fought in norgeta well that was
an interesting thing when you did go to
your back you were throwing up triangles
i was like this [ __ ] is
dangerous off his back this isn't this
is nothing this isn't a defensive guard
but i was like he's attacking but i kind
of knew i mean even though i hadn't seen
it i know who you are like you're not
going to be a guy who doesn't have
anything off your back like you you're
not going to have a hole like that
you're going to figure that out and i'm
still like i'm still learning man i'm
still a wiper like it took me five years
to get my blue belt you know under the
governor gave me my blue belt oh yeah
yeah but i was like
i'm still a wipeout training with
galvano
there but he's come over and he we are
affiliated with the school
and they have a program they don't just
give it out but like they have to like
fed them and they have a really good
relationship with my coach adam johnson
my jiu-jitsu coach and analyst and also
eugene berman so when he saw me rolling
and stuff like that i think he was like
oh
oh that's great blue belt so yeah and
then i bought
[ __ ] yeah i was just surprised like to
even get my blue belt that day but i
didn't mind i was like [ __ ] that's a
nice white girl for life
yeah and i was even looking forward to
training with um gordon ryan and then
when i was in new york but [ __ ] this
thing won't let me yeah protect your
knees man you don't want to say that
no i don't want to roll with the [ __ ]
all that no no i'm not rolling with them
just like swap skills no [ __ ] rolling
with him maybe later on but like yeah
like i just wanted to swap skills
because you know he they know some [ __ ]
like some [ __ ] about grappling that we
don't know well donahue is a legitimate
kiwi guy as well and he knows some [ __ ]
you talk to that guy you look in his
eyes there's a darkness in that guy's
soul i saw him on the podcast when he's
talking to you yes
he's intense he's like professor x i
think i was just gonna say that he's
like the real live professor x
dude he's he's spooky smart too spooky
smart so i was gonna swap some skills
with um gordon ryan and
uh what's his name uh gary gary whatever
else yeah yeah eddie cummings branched
off he's got his own uh gym now but he's
another master yeah you know those guys
are that whole it's really interesting
what happened out of that whole gym
that gem
really that was the the epicenter of the
revolution they they sort of started
this whole leg lock revolution in
jiu-jitsu
why would you ignore 50 of the human
body boom and then donahue was like
that's a switch why would you that's the
scene that was it that was the scene i
mean it really was because dean lister
was tapping people with leg locks and
heel hooks back when you would get booed
you know i remember i saw dean lister
compete in abu dhabi in sao paulo brazil
in 2003 you know and there was there was
you were there yeah yeah scared because
eddie bravo fought hoyler grayson that's
why you said yeah so i flew over with
eddie
and um i'm not crazy
dude i've never been so happy in all my
life even the last fight he had with um
what was it uh which gracie was it the
last fight eddie he fought hoyler again
toilet yes right yeah
and that um
wouldn't tap he had him in what's called
the uh what is he calling all the that
names is so much
but yeah he had his legs like this and i
could see his groin like about to tear
well his knee was [ __ ] i forget it's
some nuclear word i forget the word
vaporizer vaporizer yeah
dude he was ripping hoiler's knee apart
and as a person who's had three knee
surgeries i was watching him
i was like please just tap just tap it
ain't worth it he wasn't gonna attack
the pride but he wouldn't tap it with
anything remember when he fought
sakaraba sagaraba had a in a deep kimura
way behind his back all up like this
where it looked like his his joints were
ripping apart he wouldn't tap and they
stopped the fight yeah they stopped the
fight i have to well they didn't have to
let him get his [ __ ] up you know it'd be
like some [ __ ]
mirror did that to nogara oh bro snapped
his arm
boom pop yeah there's that moment where
it's just like [ __ ] it it's gonna go
look at his arm like this i mean uh look
at his arm like this like oh
is it oh yeah i mean his arm is never
the same again
i mean that's that's a when you get that
upper arm snapped like god damn that's a
bad that guy's a guy he's he fights like
a zombie he's the original yeah here it
is he don't
this is eddie
is tearing his [ __ ] knee apart i mean
if you if you don't if you've never
experienced what this feels like i've
only experienced it a couple times it's
a terrible feeling man it's a terrible
feeling it's hard to explain what's
going on here but oh wow yeah his knees
see that yeah it's sideways and being
mangled
and he's just and eddie said it kept
popping and hoilers just dealing with
the pain like right there
oh my god
that's mental fortitude man yeah oh man
that whole family famous savages i mean
there's never been a family that's
revolutionized martial arts the way the
gracie family did and hoyler was the
most successful of all the gracies when
it came to competition he was a
multiple-time world champion of course
he is look at his [ __ ] knee man eddie
bravo's mangling his knee and he won't
tap and eddie's telling him just tap man
he's like it's fine it's normal he's
like dude your leg just popped five
times he's like it's normal like he's
happening again eddie's got him wrapped
up nasty and this is some [ __ ] eddie
invented this is what's crazy about all
of this
i mean hoyler to his credit just would
rather get his knee torn apart than lose
when's the last time the indian came out
ready probably a couple hours ago
[Laughter]
you got to have him back over here i
love him i love that
company we were just talking on the
phone the other day and i was driving to
this area where the cell phone was about
to cut out he was telling me some crazy
conspiracy i was like blah blah blah i
love you i gotta go
i love you too man i'm sorry i choose
your ear off
i'd love to be a woman he's so crazy oh
my god he loves conspiracies he loves
conspiracy like
it's like his family number one jiu
jitsu number two
conspiracies
that's right a new one maybe his friends
number three and then conspiracies oh
everybody look into it everybody's into
that see i don't know too deep about it
but even
[ __ ] a chimp could tell you
my dog marshall
[ __ ] look man that guy bill clinton
flew with that guy 26 confirmed times 26
it might be 28 but 26 confirmed times i
i read that on my bro i didn't follow it
with my mother 26 times yeah how does
this guy fly with bill bill clinton flew
with a pedophile 26 times over the
period of some island a couple of years
[ __ ] island
[ __ ] island that's what everybody else
called it all right how to defend
against suicide
i'm loving these bees man yeah they
snapped that guy's [ __ ] neck man is
that eddie
oh of course
another one
oh they snapped that guy's [ __ ] neck
they said his neck was fractured he said
how can you do that from hanging
yourself you can't how do you how do you
hang yourself in jail dude they come out
eventually even michael shermer who's
like a professional skeptic he's the
editor of skeptics magazine okay he says
probably conspiracy even him yeah he
said what the cameras were down the
cameras weren't working
to shut up at that time get the [ __ ] out
of here they killed that dude they
killed that dude no one's talking about
it no everybody's like on the news what
[Music]
i mean there's that leak where that uh
abc reporter was saying that abc
squashed the story three years ago
that was just i just got released
hillary was on trevor noah and he kind
of asked her yeah he joked around with
her yeah but she laughed about it yeah i
was like oh i thought it was one of
those um what do you call the thing the
deep fakes but it was real no well
here's what's crazy
she knew that guy yeah she knew that guy
and that guy
was most likely murdered in jail
and she was laughing about it yeah like
because trevor noah said how did you
kill jeffrey epstein yeah but he's like
but that's like imagine if you knew
someone like and your husband was flying
around with that guy and this is like
someone you know
you got to know pretty well like you've
hung out with him at cocktail parties
like you know like maybe
you've known him for years and then that
guy gets murdered and then somebody
asked you how'd you murder him and you
start laughing like you got to be weird
you got to be a cruel
heartless person to think that's funny
that's weird joke about it that's weird
she did the same thing with when the
gaddafi stuff that was even that was
different though because that wasn't a
joke
she said we came we saw he died
but that was someone that wasn't her
friend right that's someone who wasn't a
friend right this was someone who she
knew and you know trevor and listen the
way the daily show works for sure they
told me they told her beforehand yeah i
was like they couldn't have sprung that
on her no way no way you don't spring
[ __ ] on hillary goddamn clinton when she
had all the questions in the show yeah
so she would be ready for that and then
like
she's gotta know you respect her she's
gotta i mean there's no way she's coming
on that show unless she knows
everything's gonna be okay
so when they they brought that up and
she started laughing she knew that [ __ ]
was coming i guarantee you guarantee you
guarantee you they're not free-balling
on that show she'll come out later on
i'm sure to come out later on some
people know too much man yeah way too
much it probably will be one of those
decades later things we find out you
know that some some guy on his death bed
says he killed epstein yeah because
clinton paid them off or you know who
the [ __ ] knows who knows who that guy
who knows what that guy knew i mean that
guy that that guy was a professional
blackmailer
you know i don't know who he worked for
i have no idea there's more like [ __ ]
i might just be the tip of the iceberg
[ __ ] yeah yeah the whole shitload of
things we have no idea
[ __ ] yeah yeah i'm surprised all that
kind of stuff gets into politics as well
with like um sex trafficking and whatnot
it's like rightly well i think for
billionaires you can get a guy like that
like here's a lot of these guys this is
my thoughts a lot of these guys are
freaks and then they're in the public
eye so they have to maintain them proper
we know bill clinton during the 90s in
particular there's no internet [ __ ] he
was [ __ ] like
just [ __ ] up a storm he was a wild
man
and you know and there's a a few alleged
rapes you know
yes alleged sexual assault
allegedly i mean i don't know i wasn't
there but there's women that are
accusing him of sexual assault and rape
so you got the monica lewinsky things
you know he's a freak he's getting his
dick sucked by 20 year olds and his wife
had sexual relations with that woman
and then when they bust him he's like
well as to what i thought sexual
relations were oh
yeah okay
but
you got to think
there's a lot of those dudes out there
yeah that's why they get into politics
in the first place they're all in their
60s so they got into politics in the
[ __ ] 80s and the 70s they got into
politics because they wanted to [ __ ]
they wanted to be the king they wanted
to be the guy with all the power they
wanted to be the alpha and so then all
of a sudden the rules change because of
the internet so then they got to figure
out oh my jesus i can't do anything
anymore what the [ __ ]
so what they do is they find a guy who's
going to take him to an island where
there's no rules damn man jeffrey
epstein's got this place he brings these
girls from czechoslovakia and they suck
your dick until your head explodes let's
do it
you're on the [ __ ] the boat headed to
the island with clinton you know what a
lot you had an island yeah where'd you
get that island no one knows i don't
know how you buy an island you don't the
[ __ ] intelligence agencies give you
money they give you an island they set
it up yeah someone from some agency
whether it's mossad or cia or whoever
the [ __ ] it was they had a concerted
effort most likely to try to bring these
creepers and bring them over there
attempt them
and he know how to do it i think they
probably do it as well as like having
[ __ ] over them yeah so that way they can
have like they can get them to do things
for them exactly decisions
bills that need to be passed you know uh
[ __ ] drawings like example the the
marijuana reform i'm like look we all
agree now like you know everyone smokes
everybody you know like everyone but
like everyone's doing it so
they're gonna legalize it can't they
just have like a group chat or something
and like okay all opposed say nay all
for it say aye why does it have to take
so long well the concern is
pharmaceutical companies have a massive
concern about loss of income that's big
one
even in new zealand right now it's
taking so long to get pushed and i think
they're at the tail end of it they can't
hold back anymore it's going to [ __ ]
burst it's going to burst that's what it
is it's going to be worse it's those
people have to set up their own
uh businesses and what not so that way
when it comes to boom they're first in
line to cash in the most egregious
example that is what happened in his
home state of ohio ohio tell them a
story about what they did
well i've actually been since we brought
that up the last couple of days i've
been reading that was like some
misinformation and that's not exactly
how it even is
so i don't know oh i'm not thinking like
i'm not there so i don't know but the
the bill was making it so that only a
few companies one that didn't pass a few
years ago and the one that passed this
guy
the most egregious example they proposed
a bill to legalize marijuana but
no one could grow it only a couple
companies could grow and they would make
all the profits why exactly so no one
can grow it well it's just a horseshit
and by the way this was forever like
they were like for life [ __ ] really for
life yeah their their idea was that they
were going to monopolize the state of my
heart
and everybody was like [ __ ] you you know
we'll wait like when i went to muscle
farm i was at um
this was in denver where uh we call it
um muscle farm what's the name of the
team like de la shore team elephant
elevate yeah
like right next door is this big hanger
and
i'm not a scientist but the smell in the
air
were they growing skunks bro
literally i was just like they're
growing weed 100 like literally you
could smell it i was like yeah and it's
now minty man yeah i love the smell oh
it's a beautiful smell yeah warren the
weird as well is like
as a kid because of what i was told and
what i was perpetrated whenever i'd
smell either beer because i didn't used
to drink till i was like so i found
bourbon i don't like beer long story but
then i didn't drink or did anything i
was a goody boy you know still am good
boy but once i smell
weed or beer or anything it reminded me
of homeless people like oh
dirty because of what i was taught as a
kid but then there's an adult now i'm
like where the party yet
yeah want to relax think different chill
bruh yeah
weed is a great one man because it makes
people more like uh more comfortable
with each other it makes people
friendlier it it sort of i only smoke
around certain people like i don't
that's just for me personally because i
if i don't feel comfortable
like if you know you can get into a
situation i'm just like why is that guy
on his phone because sometimes you see
people like this is the worst one man
now these days people just like this and
then they just you see their phone just
like right you know they're filming you
yeah i'm like why is your are you
texting this way
[Music]
you ain't got a text this way it's so
common weird man i'm sure you get it all
it's like all the time i would love to
do deep bond hits around donald trump
yeah i'm like bro you don't have to
smoke just hang out in the room with me
see what's up
about these kids in cages but even just
talking to him high as [ __ ] would be
weird like bro would you why don't you
just quit come on man just get out he's
one of those guys he likes the game he
likes the game i'm sure he's my favorite
comedian of this year man
i follow him on twitter just because of
the [ __ ] he says like it's [ __ ]
hilarious man you can't not respect it
he says some funny [ __ ] for sure one of
the funniest things he ever said was
when he put when he was thinking about
buying green land yeah he put a picture
of trump tower because i promise not to
do this trump tower in the middle of
greenland i was laughing my ass off
that's funny donald trump has reportedly
discussed making the apprentice white
house holy [ __ ] raiding can you imagine
if he turns the white house into a set
for a reality show
that doesn't say [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] who's that dude
producer mark burnett oh that's mark
burnett he's buddies with him see i knew
him from the apprentices i watched the
first two seasons when i was a kid yeah
you're fired yeah i remember that but
that's his that's his move yeah i've
heard i've heard some other things after
that
he said you were gonna do that but you
didn't do it well they offered it to me
when i was hosting fear factor the
second time around was like 2011 but i
talked with my family but i didn't want
to live in new york for three months and
all that nastiness i was like i'm not
interested i'm not interested you know i
don't want to pull my kids out and have
them go and i just just didn't want to
raise here yeah it just didn't seem like
a smart thing to do it just seemed like
something i'm going to be annoyed with i
didn't want to be angry at anybody i'm
just not that guy i can't do it always
now man it's months and months of your
time for me it's like
i want to get fighting now like after my
fight i kind of like because we're in
marvel stadium i kind of said something
about marvel like you know i'll see you
guys soon or whatever i said yeah but
after fighting right now like i said
they're coming from me so i got to make
sure i don't want to end up like some
others in this game where they get that
you know distracted yeah and look at you
know hollywood and the shot so i get
some offers coming to my table right now
and i'm just like
yeah nah those cautionary tales are
they're they're so readily available for
you to consume look at ronda rousey yeah
ronda rousey is the best example she's
on top of the [ __ ] world they all
came comment and she said yes to
everything she was doing everything man
she was doing movies she was doing
interviews she was writing books she was
doing and you know one thing you got to
give it to conor mcgregor i mean conor
mcgregor said no to all that [ __ ] when
he was on top he said no to all that
[ __ ] i've learned from her from him yeah
john from silva yeah from everyone like
i've seen the highs and the lows of this
game man and like i said i'll make my
own mistakes but guess what i'll bounce
right back i always will but
it's better to learn from the mistakes
you'll make less the way you're
approaching things yeah you will i know
me actually eugene
he sees me every day like that's why
sometimes i'm like
like the same rhetoric i'm your biggest
fan or you inspire me or this and i'm
like
i appreciate that if you can take
inspiration from the story that you've
seen through tv through media [ __ ] yeah
you know go hard i'm sure is it weird
still seeing your face on people's
stomachs it's very strange yeah yeah
like there's a guy um i was him dylan
shout out to dylan he's got my face on
his thigh i met him in a club in
auckland and yeah i flew my him plus
once in my last fight just because i was
like
[ __ ] good for you yeah but i'm like i
gotta have to tattoo his face on my
thigh now i don't know that'll be the
thing like if you get a style bender
tattoo you get a free ticket
how many people how many people do you
think would do that yes crazy
[ __ ] will do it just for the
law
just like oh i did it right no just for
the free tickets just ezra sonia the
last style been incorporated i do not
agree with the sentiments of jorgen in
the last speech
we would have to do it at your own risk
how about this we'd have to prove that
you got a tattoo a style bender before
blew up before before this day yeah so
this is like you can't do it it's only
two years there's only two there's only
two i can't remember the other guy's
name that's what he's doing no you only
know about two actually three there's
one chick from somewhere in south
america the brazilian girl yeah i can't
remember her name she's gonna stop being
on her arm so she look
she's all right
your face on her
back or something and some guy's hitting
her from the back and they're just like
what the [ __ ] is this that's right the
third eye looking there yeah
that's rough
a girl with your name on it though if
you met up with a fan who had your name
tattooed or your face tattooed on her
whoo that's risky that's russia when we
went with four bullets make sure people
are around for that one yes you know
everybody allegedly i don't want to
catch no build calls
so i have my hands when you take a
picture you just like yeah you do the
keanu reeves do the
air float the floating hands yeah yeah
catch no build guys i know they're
coming man i know because i've already
foreseen everything that's kind of
happening and i know this kind of shit's
coming so i just have to make sure you
know
like addison says stay focused you know
dark my eyes cross my t's make sure they
don't catch me slipping well you're
looking at it the right way because you
realize that right now you're at the
this it's like a funnel right you're at
the opening of the funnel where it's
just going to go
the options because you're you know your
newly crowned as the champion yeah and
as you defend the title and start
murking [ __ ] and become bigger
and bigger and bigger and then the ufc
puts you in more and more promos your
pay-per-view sell more and more you
become an international star then it
gets crazy then you can't go anywhere
and people are screaming when they see
you walk into a restaurant even after my
press conference in melbourne before the
fight
after the press conference the one that
the guy with the megaphone was [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me on after that that night
what was he doing yeah just some i'm
sure someone planted it because even i
asked robert after like did you pay that
guy he's like [ __ ] no i was like you
should have because he had a megaphone
and the whole time
he just kept on interrupting me on one
and i was going back and forth with him
but i liked it because guess what if he
wasn't there it would have been a boring
press conference robert he's not going
to say [ __ ] he backtracked already but
after that press conference i lit up in
the alleyway spoke up and i walked
around melbourne with my airpods in and
i just walked around the city and at one
point i just sat at the tram stop
because they didn't so i can just sit
there and people just going back and
forth and i could just sit there and
look normal and just like
soak it all in because i know eventually
i won't be able to do [ __ ] like this
after my debut in perth did the same
thing after breakfast the next day just
walked around just enjoying the view
enjoying just being me because
i'm not saying i'm gonna blow up but i
know i'm gonna blow up so i know yeah
you're gonna blow up like isis yeah you
gotta you just gotta understand what it
is and it's gonna get confusing and what
you said earlier about fame is very very
smart that you said no one really tells
you how to prepare for that and what
about you how'd you deal with it when
you were young
i got a slow drip
i got famous slow drip yeah i got a
tolerance for it because i became uh i
was on television in 1994 and nobody
knew who the [ __ ] i was i was one of
eight people on a not so successful
sitcom it was a great sitcom but it was
not so successful and then i had a
couple little television gigs on
stand-up comedy shows but nothing big
and so i would i could like kind of sell
a weekend at a club but i had to do
morning radio i wasn't famous but i was
a little bit known and then fear factor
came along that was a big jump that was
a big jump yeah that was a big jump that
was a big jump because then i was on a
giant hit television show that was
iconic was on for six years 148 episodes
it was a family time that was a big jump
but then there was um
the the podcast which came after all
that and the podcast was like a slow
run it was like it was slow you were
famous before the podcast yeah yeah i
was famous but then the podcast changed
everything so how'd you deal with it
from the big jump from you know just a
comedy and a comedian to a fair factor
guy
how do you like i used to i just got
used to it and i'm also like you in the
sense that i don't
i don't want to get caught up doing
stupid [ __ ] i don't want to think about
things the wrong way yeah you got to get
it what's going on she's your girl's in
the window who's that
five more minutes is that what she's
saying five do you have something a
heart out yeah somebody they're working
in new york literally
they're working yeah yeah
off the chain like a run away
is a trick
that works on other people
but it shouldn't work on you
you got to know who you are 100 that's
the thing if it works on you you're
[ __ ] yeah because it's like if you're
a magician you really think you pulled
the rabbit out of the hat
are you [ __ ] now man you're living in
the world of nonsense
yeah i think one thing that helps is
martial arts jiu jitsu helps like when
you go get strangled all the time
man honestly it's so overused and i've
said it before i'm like i'm like what's
humble because i've actually especially
in new zealand this is culture of like
people even like they they don't like me
because it's oh he's not he's not humble
like a true kiwi he's not you know like
the all blacks you know humble and what
they mean and i've asked people this
what does humble mean
and someone said oh you know you just
don't brag i'm like ugh
they just mean
downplaying your success yes you know so
if anyone like me
rocks up and just i'm owning it i'm like
you're owning it yeah i'm the champ i'm
the man
you're here and they say oh no he's not
humble but i tell you what humble is
when i have dan hooker on my [ __ ]
neck hangman yeah humble is when i have
stephen warby cracking me with the
uppercut humble is when i have carlos
kicking me in the body and making my
liver go
that's true humility yeah but me like
trying to act or you know dull my shine
just to make someone else feel
comfortable that's not humble and i see
that as a problem with that like crabs
in the bucket thing when kamaru was
about to win the
title a reporter asked me like you know
oh does a part of you hold hope that uh
uh kamaru loses so you can be the first
nigerian middleweight champion i was
like what [ __ ] what what reporter i
can't remember in the press conference
they asked me i was like i don't think
like that that that doesn't no no but
that doesn't work yeah he was hoping i'd
say something like that he was trying to
i see them i've banned someone already
like i don't do any interviews with them
if they talk to me i just next you know
i had that episode of black mirror when
you block someone i've blocked him i
would report with that and you know
record with that as well yeah they they
take a cheap shot and they don't
understand like that's you man now
you're that guy that takes those cheap
shots yeah and everybody's gonna
remember that yeah yeah i mean you think
you're just trying to get make some
noise make a little pop but you're
creating bad energy and also no reason
it's not you're trying to get something
for now you're not thinking of longevity
yeah because in the future i'm not going
to talk to you now what is it about
nigerians
that why why are nigerians so clever all
these internet scams like when you hear
about internet scams it's nigerians
right nigerians come to america they're
one of the most successful groups of
immigrants in all you all the [ __ ]
countries 100 plus whatever countries
nigerians murder it when they come to
america there's something about there's
a work ethic but there's also a
cleverness yeah to nigerians i've said
it i've said it before i'm the runt of
my people brain wise body wise because
when i went back recently
honestly man you see people who are just
bricklaying and they are jacked
they are ripped some of them and they
don't maybe have the best nutrition
right no but they there's something
about the genetics of our people it's a
warrior race and i don't say that likely
i'm just being honest right it's
different you know and
i think also the culture because i was
doing algebra in school when i was like
seven
and then i went to i remember when i
first moved to new zealand
form one i had to do form one in three
different countries so i started form
one i don't know what you guys have here
form one sound like first grade ah i
don't know how it is but pretty much i
was 10 years old and i moved to ghana
for a little bit and i just repeat it
again then i moved to um new zealand
then i had to repeat it again because
they said no he's too young he can't be
doing that but thing is i wasn't even
the smartest i was the bottom three in
my class so i wasn't the smarter the
smartest of the bunch in nigeria in
nigeria so when i came to new zealand
form one remember my first day in school
they had a test like you know early
workout or something or one of the first
weeks in school and we had to do times
table
and i knew the song in my head so i just
like
finish miss and all the kids like
and i'm just like
the [ __ ] and then like they all thought
i was just [ __ ] savant this genius
and then like they start asking me
questions like you know
do you brush your teeth
[Laughter]
yes i do
like back home do you
ride on lions and i went home and i was
like mom these [ __ ] kids are dumb
stupid like i didn't know i didn't
understand i just thought like
you know i do regular [ __ ] like i but
they didn't understand me so
yeah my people are different man
honestly and i'm like you've seen it and
i'm telling you man especially right now
the what i want to do in nigeria i
really
i want to introduce them like take the
football soccer ball out of their hands
and show them some gloves
we have some great boxes we have this
thing called dambe which is nigerian
wrestling kind of like the senegalese
type wrestling
you know they wrap rope around the one
hand just one hand and they just pull
with the other hand and they wrestle and
they throw strikes but also they have
like some juju some black magic you know
all that kind of stuff like they
sprinkle that in there i got my own as
well at 3am you know
but um literally i can't wait to like
show them like because when i went back
i i was trying to just chill low-key
sneak into the country but my dad said
it can't happen they're watching you
everyone knows who you are from the
airport all the area boys israel this on
yeah oh my god ah can i take a photo
police officers showing what's up
showing love crooked police officers
some of them
they're sharing what's up showing love
and like i didn't realize like they they
stay up til 4am to watch me and kamaru
fight wow they're staying up and i've
always said i wanted to be the guy
like what pacquiao was to the
philippines yeah you know the way
when he fights the whole country shuts
down crime drops everything yeah i want
it to be like i feel like after this now
it's going to keep blowing up and i'm
going to go back next year i'm going to
go back next year i'm going to
i'll hope i hope they see the
possibilities because i'm telling you
man the countries i mean it was brazil
at first in the early stages of mma then
japan then america then you know like it
always goes back and forth and then you
know the oceania people right now we're
doing some work i'm telling you once not
just nigerians wants to africans once
they start stepping in
it's gonna be like when 50 cent dropped
in the club and killed the whole game
for a while like honestly i'm telling
you like they're gonna run the game for
a long time for a long time and i'm
i'm happy to be a guy that's kind of
like paving the way it's crazy though
what was it like going back there being
the champ going back there it was
beautiful like just seeing my people
it's different when you're in vegas and
oh my god dude i'm your biggest fan oh
my god
but it's different when you see like
a kid just in shock that you're even
standing there
like just in shock that you're in his
presence and for me i don't see myself
as a stauben i'm israel i disagree at
the end of the day but when they're
looking at you and just like
you know and this kid i remember like
it's on my instagram he was kicking the
bag and i just showed him i tweaked him
i just told him just to turn pivot on
the foot
stand on the toes and turn the hip
literally within a minute he improved
his kick like that and i got it on my
instagram somewhere but man i was really
impressed and that was just a little
snippet of the
of the the the the creativity of our
people look at that the way oh man
that's gonna make me cry this is my old
primary school man like going back here
i was looking i used to hide there for
hide and seek and everything seems so
small because when you're a kid
everything's so big this is me at i
think uh leki beach just chilling with
the people man i was immersed in the
culture seeing all those kids with their
uniforms on grabbing at your belt that's
amazing honestly man it was like it
reminded me of [ __ ] goosebumps again it
reminded me of this gym here uh this is
just um uh
uh look at the stadium i went there to
go watch and then the guy that the
trainer was like sure you're not
training i'm like what do you mean he's
like you are training get up
okay i had my [ __ ] nice jordans on
and i just had to like work he made and
i think he was trying to flex he was
trying to show me like you i'm gonna
work you right right he put us to work
and that's me on holiday as well this is
open state what is this video can people
watch this yeah go on instagram we'll go
on emg emg um
what do you call it emg access it says
uh israel the last style bender adasanya
into youtube emg youtube engaged media
group that's beautiful yeah but there's
some more we're doing a documentary
right now because and they've like
jeff's been following me around since
2015 and i want to like this is the i
want to say this is the end of the first
documentary but the beginning of the
next one i want to show what i can do in
nigeria what i can do in africa because
even um
kamaru went to makoko we almost well
almost died there we were then there
were some killers you see how that play
go back jamie go back
see how that place go back forward
it's like a maze go for it yeah see how
that's like a maze yeah the first day we
went there i went there just trying to
like show love to the hood say what's up
and all this area boy is like
uh oh god what thing they do here like
what are you doing here and i'm like i'm
just looking around your eye you kind of
you're set to loss like you got to
settle them you got to make sure they're
are right i was like don't worry we'll
look after you guys but then within the
first five minutes me and abiola my
friend who came with me he's like we got
to go because he's very smart he's very
very wrong so we're like and i had a guy
with the ak with me a security guard and
the guys the gangsters they were kind of
flexing i was like oh [ __ ] you guys then
so the next day
see that's the [ __ ] in me i went
there shirtless all my chains on [ __ ]
fast and i got like more security with
me with more aks and went deep we didn't
have to go deep to get that sky shot and
jeff hates me for it because he [ __ ]
panicked the whole time
and i went deep and there's all these
killers man like literally i'm talking
like you see scars on them like marks
because that's the bodies the body
counts and [ __ ] like that and this one
dude looked like kimbo slice and he's
like the the head honcho and he was
arguing with this other guy because they
were saying like no i'm giving them the
torah what they give us is my money and
i'll sell it to you and he's like no i'm
you know i'm the big dog you report to
me and they were kind of having an
argument about it and it was real heated
and if they wanted to [ __ ] us up right
there and say [ __ ] you guys that's a
[ __ ] maze they know that [ __ ] like
the back of their hand right i have no
idea you know we're [ __ ] and you're
walking through it exactly and you're
walking on planks in the water you saw
the water it's [ __ ] dirty like
disgusting you know but that's like one
of the slums in nigeria but then you see
the before the shot that was victoria
island that's like the contrast of
nigeria you have
dirt poor
and you have well-off like lamborghinis
like people living nicely those are
i don't know
i'm not your uncle don't check your
emails yeah
i'm a nigerian prince don't worry you'll
get your money just wait it's just the
fees the fees gotta like
the way the bank accounts set up all
that kind of stuff yeah
it's amazing that they figured it out to
the point where that is synonymous with
scams it's like you saw that in syrian
scams yeah you hear about and that's the
thing like we're scamming but a lot of
them it's because of the opportunity
they're so smart but the opportunity
isn't there so they can't go to school
they can't do that so they don't hear
about the guy who sold a [ __ ] airport
that didn't exist
to japan really remember that one a
nigerian dude sold a [ __ ] airport
that wasn't a real airport we're winning
yeah i know many people do that with
like buildings or airbnbs but that's a
[ __ ] airport airport
okay bro he sold an airport [ __ ] the
japanese are smart too man that's the
thing
well yeah we we talked about it like a
couple of weeks ago yeah it's
bonkers yeah they they spent a [ __ ] load
of money it was like in the 80s or
something the 90s oh really yeah they
got to make a movie about that well they
should here it goes 242 million [ __ ] off
sold a fake airport for 242 million
how do you do that it's [ __ ] nigerian
man now like i'm saying this is like
this is not the best representative of
our people but it shows you how smart
well
if you're stuck and you got nowhere out
and you're living in that maze that's
the way out exactly you got to do what
you got to do
when i was in dubai i don't know if i
should say the story i was gonna
[ __ ] it no one's listening um we're on
the boat for someone's birthday party
and i'm seeing all these kids
like 17 16 18 with like iced out rolexes
you know i'm on a yacht partying for
some guy's birthday and they're just out
there flexing and i'm just like what do
you do so oh i invested in bitcoin early
boy they call them yahoo boys because
you know but i i knew already but thing
is they're so smart they know how to
work they know how to like and they're
all over the world like i said we're
like a virus where nigerians are
everywhere wherever you look in the
world we're everywhere and we have our
claim but i can't wait till this
documentary man like i really want to
like
show people over there like what we can
do i want to show first of all the story
like it's not going to be like
you know mcgregor's documentary was dope
but it was more catered to the mma fans
and anyone can watch it but i want this
to be more like the soccer mom can watch
it you know someone from the burbs
someone from alaska can watch it and
still relate so i wanna there's
different there's different levels to
this but i'm looking forward to really
putting that out are you thinking about
opening gyms over there
in nigeria yeah yeah eventually i want
to kid out some of the gyms like the one
i went to um the
the stadium sports stadium i was at i
want to help them out with some stuff
that's later on when i go through right
and normally i do things like this like
when i went there i did some stuff but i
don't do it for like it's really weird
when you're on this platform and i see
people trying to do [ __ ] for the likes
yeah for me i cringe because i can't do
that but when you have a platform like
this and you can bring attention to
certain
causes and certain people
then i don't mind using my platform for
[ __ ] like that so i really want to bring
some attention to my people because i
feel like
they deserve it but also they can earn
it they can earn it and i know they can
man i can't wait to show the
i'm the first man camaro is the first
i'm the second you see guys like sadiq
first time i watched him fight live have
you seen him fight live yes adelaide
i was watching him cage side and he was
hitting this guy with body shots you
could hear the
like the pounding and i was just like
wow in this last fight he shot some like
what do you call it um some fortitude as
well because he got hit he got cracked
and then he cracked the guy and dropped
him
i'm telling you man there's a few more
coming and i can't it'll be fantastic if
you open up a gym there and start being
a proven ground a train of gems i really
want to open a chain of gyms even maybe
it doesn't have to be ufc gyms but you
know they can get involved yeah they can
get a cut oh well ufc i'm sure would be
excited about doing that now you know i
mean they'll see what's happening yeah
it'd be a great thing for them too just
ufc i don't know if it's going to be in
nigeria but ufc africa either nigeria
morocco or south africa
but
because they have good places to watch
over there that they have it said 100
yeah but
the thing is the red tapes you got to
cross i'm sure they can get through
those i had that and do you see how that
in china as well right now one of the
shows i can't remember which one this is
one of the early ones they were
threatening to cut the power after a
certain time so you know they had to
settle some people
to keep the keep the lights on shackles
yeah exactly and that's easy for them
you know the university they got money
yeah i've seen that a couple bucks a
couple a little bit yeah listen man you
got to get the [ __ ] out of here why
thanks for coming
you're lying it's 2 30 man [ __ ] off yeah
flies in this room this is a time zone
it is like the woody hyperbolic time
chamber yeah listen brother i'm happy
with what's happening to you
it's great to see that you're doing
everything the right way man it's a it's
it's an honor it's an honor to have you
in here and it's it's it's special for
me to watch someone go through that
special navigate honestly i have no idea
my old boss used to get mad at me
because she'd be like get that out of
your air because i'd have like one
headphone in and i'll just be like
and then i'll do it on the side she
can't see so for me to have like you
brian redbin you know i think young
jamie was out here back then as well see
way back in the day but like literally
like it was just cool just to be here
and do this [ __ ] like [ __ ] it's all
manifestation it's crazy keep going man
that's how the world works we in the
matrix you're showing everybody too
though exactly oh man
all right that's right brother respect
to you
bye everybody
[Music]